une production du studio sfr ni eau sans
filtre le podcast on parle de ce qu'on
veut nous inviter date si tu cherches
quand un mois deux plantes
cette semaine sans filtre et présentait
encore une fois par paul islip police
l'ip le 1er juillet s'en vient à grands
pas il ya beaucoup de monde qui déménage
police les organisent un petit quizz un
petit concours en fait tout est ce que
vous devez répondre à un quiz je vais
mettre le lien vers le quiz dans la
description du podcast puis vous courez
la chance de gagner votre déménagement
en fait fait que si vous déménagez vous
ça vous tente de vous faire payer les
frais de déménagement mais policiers
pour gagner ce petit concours le sur le
site qui va être écrit dans la décision
de la vidéo puis sinon si vous avez
besoin de vous mettre les noms ces
déménagements ça veut aussi dire souvent
changé de matelas ou changer de meubles
donc si vous avez un vieux matelas
croûte et le sacré se vidange puis
achetez vous un nouveau matelas avec
polisse l'ip d'un cas de propos
d'enfoncer sans filtre sans vous allez
rentrer ça dans le lien juste en dessous
alors 100 $ de rabais sur votre matelas
ce qui est quand même nom dirigeants
mais c'est extrêmement cool puis si vous
habitez en quelle dans certains secteurs
à montréal pour les slips font une
livraison à vélo ce qui est ce qui est
vraiment une scène
ensuite tu sois vous pouvez profiter de
meilleures nuits de sommeil à partir de
maintenant en utilisant un code promo
sans filtre sans un mot pardon
avec 101 chiffres d'ims au moment du
check out
donc merci à police libre d'encourager
le sans-fil podcast merci de nous faire
confiance puis merci à vous de faire
confiance à paul islip avec 1 100 $ de
rabais sur votre matelas sinon au sans
filtre aujourd'hui six semaines le grand
retour de jay du stade jean storm qui
étaient aux premiers invités qui était
le troisième en fait pas de casque on a
sorti pileux en fait c'est la première
fois officiellement conquis un invité
qui revient à part entière donc c'est
super le fun
jay on l'avait reçue à un moment
charnière pour lui avant qu'il parte
pour la deuxième saison de haut débit
va passer pour la troisième saison de
haut des vacances vraiment différent du
premier où on n'était plus dans le
développement personnel a atteint ses
objectifs puisque dépasser ce podcast je
pense qu'ils vendent en inspirer plus
d'un autre que moche très inspiré en ce
moment j'ai le goût d'aller soit à
courir un marathon ou juste me devenir
une meilleure personne
j'essaie vraiment un bel instrument et
puis je pense vraiment transparu dans ce
podcast le puits en fait une grande
nouvelle puis voilà je vous en a parlé
un petit peu on n'a pas dans le podcast
c'est que ici au studio sans filtre ont
non seulement afin de ne pas casser
ciment aussi produire et réaliser des
podcasts pour d'autres personnes dont
des dessins des premières personnes que
nous contacter pour ce projet l'ofppt
était super enthousiaste lui c'est comme
un petit intégral d'enfants avant son
propre pas de casque mais l'aspect
technique sur 71 - accueillons on lui
offre finalement l'espace l'équipement
ce pot pour qu'ils puissent faire son
podcast
donc ça va commencer bientôt cette
histoire là on vous venez au courant
mais on en a parlé plus largement dans
le podcast line pilote dans le fond
c'est le premier podcast officiel que
vous allez voir qui se passe dans nos
studios nouveau studio qu'on est très
fier en ce moment qui s'appelle le
studio sf badugi lancement du studio sf
il va le site web y voir tout le kit gc
le premier de plusieurs podcasteurs qui
vont en voir un peu de casse une tribune
sur le studio sf si vous avez des idées
de personnes qui vous trouveriez
intéressante pour animer un podcast que
ce soit un podcast nichons un podcast du
général écrit lisa des commentaires
nous on est à la recherche en ce moment
on a déjà une base monde à la recherche
d'une équipe incroyable pour un créer du
contenu de la plus grande qualité
tout ça c'est extrêmement extrêmement
existe en effet que rester à l'affût
pour ce sur toutes les plateformes
on va vous en parler on retrouve leurs
chèques sont donc inquiétez vous pas que
vous allez en entendre parler dans tout
ce qu'on veut c'est de dire public ira
du canada péter v dans le fond ils sont
venus le
jag note aaa mais dit merde que c'est un
projet qui nous tient vraiment à coeur
puis merci d'être là avec nous merci de
nous encourager dans tout ça commenter
la vidéo abonnez vous à nos chaînes
encore une fois on le répète toujours on
a lepage pétrone le super g doit
commencer à faire des podcasts avec des
invités un petit peu moins connus qui
vont permettre d'aller dans des tailles
d'emprunter qui me renald histoire qui
mérite d'être connue donc allé voir sur
nos tâches récurrentes tout ça va être
dans la déception de podcasts en ce
moment donné même si la règle ça fait
son bout de chemin
pis non profiter la conversation avec
jay du temps car c'est que mon podcast
bonne écoute c'est parti
arrête premier podcast seulement vont
voir sur dans notre studio dieu c'est
incroyable c'est le sauna c'est
incroyable et je sais que je fais partie
de l'équipe du studio
ceci dit tous vous revient à vous deux
j'essaie la plus grande par sa palette
qu'on me fait peur et je trouve ça
fascinant le timing commence à saigner
comme comment la vie fait bien les
choses c'est qu'on se rend compte dans
le contexte de haut d un côté un peu
podcast ensemble avant ma deuxième
saison
piqué on partage studio avant ma
troisième saison et même des couettes
fascinante est vrai en plus quand tu m'a
appelé ph pour est pour partie ce projet
là je revenais d'une semaine seul dans
un chalet à lire à écouter de la musique
bien que des podcasts puis rzeszow venu
avec un espèce de d'urgence vraiment une
urgence je dois me partir podcast
maintenant important s'appauvrit et je
te jure la journée que je suis revenue
je m'appelle un ouais je dirais qu'on
fera pas cas j'aimerais que quelques
passages studio pictet repas casher mais
où est ce une luge ou de cash et 0 et
les hôtes et réclamé des affaires des
hasards d'un même des fois je me dis
qu'ils sont déconnectés même c'est fou
mais c'est ton point de vue de ce qui
s'est passé mais pour nous c'est
pratiquement la même chose parce que
c'est moi mais j'arrive à dom après on
venait de thé plein potière abeilles qui
préfère cette caisse qui serait même ce
serait de partir un studio
d'enregistrement où est ce que des gens
comme jay du temple qui nous avait parlé
qui aimeraient peut-être sa part pas de
casque parce que nous avons un petit
carnet d'être s'intéresser à ce que le
dr comme pas le temps dit on pour s
occuper toute la technique puis après ça
c'est lui pourrait juste avoir besoin
c'est que tu peux pas y est enfin là
diop se dit tiens c'est vrai que ça
serait malade c'est mais j'étais
vraiment occupé le je pense pas que ça
pourrait l'intéresser pelote de mes mots
dit même que justin écrire juste écrire
si j'avais ton numéro de take him and
voici le projet puis senio et je me
rappelle j'étais assis je m'en allais
chercher le brevet gesher vise à côté de
chez nous j'étais assis dans mon champ
j'envoie le texte le jeu d'europe
montciel à côté de moi je commence à
angoisser les efforts pour sortir le
chat le s'élever strelok 15 secondes
après que tu ailles texte et c'est toi
en led match qui me répond stoïque le
choix on peut s'appeler oui même ce soir
on s'appelle pas du tout intense et agen
je me souviens parce que ce qui est
drôle c'est que tu m'écris le lendemain
de mon retour piste était chez a lieu au
studio d'alex champagne et alexis grc je
tenterai de leur parler je tenterai la
syrie de se jeter comme je voyais je
peux trop jeter on parlait de podcasts
comme je veux m'en partir un lieu je
cherche un appui aux autres leurs vagues
dans le champagne est un peu seul c'est
un peu comme tu fais ta propre site
exactement au moment où je vous parle
est d'être là j'ai sorti mon téléphone
petit mes écrits fait que c'était juste
comme j'ai fait chez qui tout ça tout ça
fait longtemps justement qui se tasse de
0,8 à peut-être déjà décodé il y avait
la partie entre vue de quitter déjà
ouais quand même en fait ce qui est
space voir la fiche de mon podcast c'est
une affiche qui que j'ai ma graphiste et
monde avec becker elle avait fait
complètement marianne et en 2006 ce qui
c est elle qui fait aussi marianne
plaisance qui est extraordinaire a fait
toutes mes affiches de chaudes depuis
des one depuis de 2013 puis
dans le fond en 2016 brandissent comme
j'aimerais ça partir podcast près une
forme affichée avec mon logo ben
ceinture et fait que j'avais cette
affiche lieu dans ma banque d' affiches
des puces pas longtemps puis j'ai fait
deux pages avaient utilisé pour un show
zoofest que j'ai fait mais j'ai fait
quand j'ai le projet d'ériger un mec
super coup des factions c'est drôle
parce que tu es j'avais tp un genre de
pilote en gros guillemets chez nous avec
4 levac en 2016 puis j'avais fait mes
leçons était mauvais et puis je connais
tellement rien atlan piger pas j'ai pas
ce mois en moitié du monde que c'est
comme je connais pas ce puis je vois
tout apprendre parce que limoges comme
je rien ça je suis vraiment paraît
seulement j'ai rien écouté au cégep
techniquement je suppose et est capable
de passage ici un cinémomètre occasion
je connais fort car le mongolisme exposé
mais c'est incroyable il faut vraiment
que ça m'intéresse c'est ce qui
m'intéresse c'est tout là puisque seule
la partie facile c'est parti c'est trop
facile tellement bon puis c'est là où je
trouve que je trouve ça tellement gentil
et généreux fin et quand je reviens pas
que tu puisses tu es comme justement oui
on va on va t'aider à face au trio sait
vraiment si on l'a vu enlever notre
podcast à nous à quel point à chaque
jour du nouveau monde qui découvre des
conversations comme ça du monde
commandes qui déjà été j'ai appris sur
tte la forme à votre podcast a changé
mon opinion sur telle chose
puis je trouve que c'est important
puis dans tout ce projet là tu nous on
se garde quand même le choix des pâtes
ya star avec qui on va travailler mais
on derrière tout seul comme l'idée de de
tous ensemble d'essayer de pousser la
réflexion plus loin tous ensemble
essayer de favoriser les nuances bilal
là
communication pitts et c'est vraiment un
projet qui d'autre quand tu aimes faire
quelque chose ça te demande pas vraiment
d'énergie les séneçons on met beaucoup
de temps là dedans mais je devrais en
mettrait deux fois plus puissant pitié
on entend très humblement je pense de
créer quelque chose qui existe c'est
vrai qu'il sait pas vraiment quel s y
met le joueur spoiler météo on fait un
tournant parce que sa fille et boucar
diouf ya puis à la fin et et j'ai jamais
parlé aussi longtemps de biologie de
sciences qui ses fans qui ont leurs
suppôts trick sénécal sida ias qui est
venu il sortit de blé d'hiver je pensais
pas parler de cinéma de michael année
kiffan et kubrick aujourd'hui thé puis t
on aux roms on n'a pas l'occasion
d'aller aussi deep qui lui le podcast
permet ce puis moi je pense que
justement c'est un médium qui est en
pleine effervescence puis que les gens
aient un appétit pour ce pot pour des
vraies discussions entre êtres humains
et et sa forme au ca sans agenda ou
santé sans limites sans questions
pratiques sexistes signe des affaires
qui fait en sorte que c'est une des
choses qu'on dit souvent je veux jamais
me plaindre de ce mois j'espère que des
fois ça me stresse pas peur mais je
jamais pas gérer j'ai déjà rien et ça
m'est arrivé de caen j'ai commencé en
humour évidemment j'ai toujours eu mes
parents mon bac et j'ai jamais été près
de cambrai demain béni des dieux
oui mais ceci dit dans mon travail dans
mon milieu
j'ai déjà fait ça m'est arrivé de me
lever le mardi matin après avoir du
monde jacques et l'avait enfin les
patchs ou de la semaine quelque chose
dans ce cas je serais je sans la payer
j'ai des trucs à payer tapez jeu pendant
mardi mais reste que tu veux être un
adulte qui vis je veux jamais apprendre
faire l'appel et les années les baffes
et parents pour demain c'est sûr est-ce
que et mais je conduis dans le fond la
raison pour laquelle c'est un honneur
pour moi
de vouloir et de tenir en partir pour
casser pour ce que vous venez juste de
dire c'est que dans ma tête si ça va
juste être bénéfique même pour moi c'est
un peu égoïste par exemple laquelle je
veux le faire parce que je sais que moi
ça va m'amener beaucoup humainement
parce que en écoute et physique est
fascinant c'est que le trouvent fatigué
dans l'appareil a subi je sais que la
journée je veux partir mais c'est l'eau
la roumanie c'est une grosse blague ça
fais ce que tu veux je pense même que
c'est parti même si je sais c'est la
raison pour laquelle qui est dans
l'intensité c'était super important de
prendre le temps de le faire parce que
je sais que ça va être à chaque fois que
je t'ai et des podcasts c'est fun oui
tellement le fun et ce sera les places
où je suis le plus rire quand je suis le
plus drôle puis est immense et que
j'arrive je me mets aucune pression
c'est juste moi même c'est alors que ça
m'est arrivé de partir de celle phaneuf
à la télé je suis vraiment pas le push
sur l'île mais ça arrive il faut de
faire de partir d'une plastie d'un
tournage télé c'est comme pour tout que
je t'avais face à jimpo
j'ai testé carey mais comme c'était quoi
sert-il terracher t'arrange c'était
toujours habiteront will de passe droit
de porter ce précieux don on le vit lot
quotidien
on a appris rapidement elle a laissé
aller certaines affaires ouais mais tu
n'as tu pas de casser des bus et tu
t'écoutes puis le pilote du mans à qui
on a certains tics langagiers on a
certaines affaires qui souhaitait
c'était moyen pertinent comme truc mais
ça fait partie de la forme et ça fait
partie du truc puis une fois que tu
acceptes le fait que des trucs comme ça
vont arriver des moments plus au creux
des moments et même en fait exact une
fois que tu acceptes que l'imparfait
existe mais là depuis de pression quand
arrive c'est comme le tout arriver si je
devais
j'ai jamais été nerveux un matin elle
jamais de la vie à matin je sais juste
j'avais juste hâte d'arriver ici me
couler un petit café d'attendre faire
une conversation pis c'est ce à chaque
fois c'est sûr que c'est que nous on a
quand même une relation de ces kits
établi c'est sûr que bien d'autres sont
plus très bien acheter un petit peu plus
nerveux ah oui pas de relation je ne
savais pas si on vous voyez où tutoyer
on pourra me employés mais sinon deux
minutes de conversation c'est parti
c'est ce qui est le fun c'est ce qu'ils
font c'est qu'ils aient fait penser à un
enfant que j'ai complètement pas oui les
moments parfaite c'est juste un nom
enfin l'année passée j'ai fait j'ai fait
des entrevues ou non devant un public à
zoofest qui s'appelait je veux tout
savoir en tipi qui est un projet que
j'ai encore en tête que je vais
peut-être amené à quelques pas puis
remaniée ferme as tu mon podcast pas mon
cas j'ai pas trop ce que je vais enfin
cm et on m'avait proposé de le phare
télé puis on était rendu en alerte et
les ti pierre monnet était comme moi
c'était des formats de 60 je faisais des
60 minutes
chose que je trouve est relativement
courte et mais j'étais comme ça veut
dire on pouvait pas faire plus longue
liste des vainqueurs expliqué luc la bm
et finalement téléphon on va le mettre
en 22 minutes et moi non je pense ici à
1,44
ah non on va juste prendre les meilleurs
moments puis on va mettre ça en mai 2005
tellement moche comme je comprends
complètement
je comprends vraiment vraiment vu ce que
puis je sais que vous avez sûrement
raison
faut vraiment vous avez raison mais il
ya une partie de man qui tenait à ce que
ce soit un parfait on résume oui piquer
les gens soient témoins des moments plus
haut depuis plus eu depuis que c'est
comme jusqu'à dresser des humains qui
parle puisqu'elle est gens qui écoutent
à la télé un peu l'impression d'avoir
été assise dans sa halle d'avoir assisté
à une vraie conversation s'est dit qu'il
est très grosse affaire de celestina
rester comme ça m'intéresse pas du tout
j'ai appelé ma soeur imaginons puisque
fou de refuser une émission télé amont
au public et c'est un luxe mais il me
disait on ne touche pas au contenu tu
fais ce que tu veux les invités que tu
veux tu parles de ce que tu veux on
touche à rien quel luxe j'avais la carte
blanche il ya personne qui est sur c
sport mais j'étais comme non je veux
plus masai comme institut für bosque et
sam suivait tellement le trouve
tellement chanceux celle où finalement
ça j'ai fait c'est quoi ça parce que les
termes a beau père on pourrait le mettre
en 44 minutes dans le temps des fêtes
est prêt de les spéciales du temps des
fêtes on voit là haut mais la version
longue c'est comme vous arrive quand on
met paul 22 minutes pendant l'automne
pour fait juste les spéciales
je ne mets pas vide et 11 ans je
comprends un peu cécité est aujourd'hui
je regrette pas du tout de pas l'avoir
fait peut-être que ça a été super
positive que je le fasse mais c'est ce
que j'aime du podcast c'est que c'est
sans pression c'est sincère c'est vrai
c'est relax pisser c'est tellement fun à
écouter le sting vraiment c'est vraiment
le fun a écouté ce que vous ça vous
arrive de croiser ce monde que ce qu'ils
font de ce podcast et que ça vient comme
la petite comme comme la musique c'est
que tu accompagnes légende
moi j'étais jobs login shalem un point
où je me trouve où je sais gnl intégrés
mais mes amis doivent commencer
probablement ma blonde encore plus que
mes amis mais doivent commencer à me
trouver tannant de parler de ligue 1 ou
2 ou de commencer pratiquement toutes
mes interventions par jacques talbot que
oui exact mais ceci dit c'est que c'est
tellement riche pis s'il y en a
tellement
mais tu vois les pc que j'en parle
tellement que ma grande soeur qui
écoutait pas d'époque gaza fait que et à
cause de touche le sma et coûtera 1,6 à
t elle
ts une mère à la maison est mort qui est
dit pierre comment j'ai trouvé un
podcast de mer qui est vraiment
intéressant
j'aime faut suivre comme facebook il ya
un podcast pour ce que tu veux examinant
les patrons un peu ça aussi on veut 6 2
là on a une base de pâte castor
intéressante pour cet art est simple
mais ça va être d'aller chercher plus ça
va aller plus à plus le podcast va être
connue au québec qu on va aller chercher
des podcasts n'est chienlit mecs qui
vont qui vont attirer d'autres mondes
qui financent pas les podcasts mon
pouvoir intéresser des gens qui
s'intéressent pas nécessairement à ce
que ce que nous nous fait même plus en
plus c'est clairement chaque fiche parle
à quelqu'un qui veut se partir un
podcast comme hugo au pire ça existe
c'est là dans ce sens je comprends le
côté mon et tarifs damanaki doute mais
ces gens-là fois où je fais la journée
aux jeunes c'est comme le g1 podcast
mais si ammann est jeune on tue des gens
de partir un autre goût ou 10 comme ça
existe et ce qui est six et que
quelqu'un qui découvre le sans filtre
podcast aujourd'hui il ya tellement de
bon stock
les quarante fois deux heures à écouter
c'est tellement trippant sais c'est
qu'ils font une section début 28 votes
écoute les invités tu connais way qui a
presque le plus intéressante aussi quand
tu tombes personnes et le sais pas moi
c'est ce qui me fait triper de voir
aucune chance à 7 et j'écoutais un truc
qui me fait le plus tripes et c'est avec
le collen o'bready le geek est traversé
l'antarctique à pied puis mène c'est
fascinant fascinante un gars whisky et
je pense qu'à 30 ans ou 30 trop il ya
monté les les sept plus gros sommet du
monde en le moins de temps au monde et
il a traversé l'antarctique à pied c'est
quand joe rogan est impressionné par
d'un gars qui sait quand attendre au 25
m 2 je te parle depuis je me sens comme
un gros large choix imagine moi comment
je ressens joe rogan chute à marseille
il va chercher ces personnes là ces
personnes là qui repousse les limites
qui vont plus loin que l'humain jamais
aller il était logique théodore par alex
auld qui les occupent le documentaire
suit solo c'est donc moi qui suis py qui
montre le plus grand mur que jamais été
monté à l'écart
ça sans attache le titre jusqu à minuit
le disent complètement foule c'est
complètement fou ce ticket du monde fou
métier aussi lol il est temps qu'elle
fournit ouais c'est une zone située au
zénith est le capitaine ils le montrent
et déjà des centaines et des centaines
de fois avec une corde avec plus y avait
son capteur exact ok je connaissais
toutes les cracks piscine avec lui c'est
parti ce matin c'est dire qu'ils sont
prêts c'est que l'italie pas de code
ils savent exactement coffart tac tac
tac tac tac je pense à et prend 4 à
monter en haut il ya quelque chose de
cassé mais aujourd'hui je risque ma vie
fin j'étais allé voir je le soutiens je
t'avais gus à ce principe et j'allais
voir les deux choses une seule oeuvre
depuis ho ho chi moche les deux m'ont
jetée à terre mais au particulièrement
rester avec coûtent chacune émouvant
puis de bobby il y avait tellement de
moments où tu es d'accord je peux pas
croire que les artistes du cirque et moi
on fait partie du monde ensemble
si genacol ces gens là risquent leur vie
pour cent requis ni utilement mais jeter
comme je regardais puis j'avais
tellement d'admiration plus de respect
pour d'autres fins si c'est oui des fois
il sort des filets puis sa mère est ce
qu'il ya des mots que seulement 6 pour
ta journée donne notre médecin est
tellement dévoué de tellement tellement
tu travailles tu défends je monte sur
mur le une centaine de fois point tout
compris et mal connaître un moment que
ça prend quatre à remonter par casino
talent
il avait cette fois qu'elle suivait type
de repousser ses propres limites
il ya maintenant quatre postes moi c'est
quelque chose qui m'a dit camille jeanne
mairie beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup dit
dans le monde entier tire vraiment une
heure une strate de gens qui frôle la
compréhension pour qu'il faut
l'incompréhension complète pour moi le
type ouais c'est le même principe
mettant témoin g
j'ai passé ma vie en danger le quai puis
j'ai réussi à être bond un certain point
puis le niveau michael phelps le sait le
niveau ultime lancer même je suis même
pas capable de comprendre je cavale de
comprendre le niveau est ce que moi je t
il et il aime les meilleurs au canada de
retirer mais il ya une affaire en eau de
turquie qui est comme vraiment une ligne
une fois qu'ils dépassent cette ligne là
j'comprends puis qu'est ce qui s'passe
comprend pub c'est la même chose qui est
un gage
j'écoutais un documentaire sur sur
youtube qui s'appelle beyond sud puis
c'est nike dans le fond est en fait un
spot publicitaire y ont pris les 3 3 des
meilleurs coureurs au monde pour essayer
de leur faire courir un marathon en
bottes 2h20 grelet nom qui sort chacun
fait que jal est est de mettre toute les
tout ce que je pouvais mettre dans la
direction de cours et en bottes de genre
puis le gars qui gagne et il y a deux
captures guechi lucky luke a le record
du monde du marathon c'est lui qui a
fait 2 heures 25 secondes
mais merci quand tu t'es une meilleure
au monde petit déçu tout le monde est
content parce qu'il vient d'europe et
son bestiaire de trois minutes mais lui
fait comme le documentaire ça peut être
bien de tous et pas réussi mais sega
mandat personnel inquiet quand je veux
dire ici le au québec.le quelqu'un court
2 30 au marathon c'est un malade mental
est en cours de 30
c'est évident qu'ils risquent je
comprends pas même les marathoniens
comme pâtissier travailler aux
entraînements de tremblant 2012 moi
c'est quelque chose qui est sûre la
france et je pense ça vient peut-être
avoir grandi dans le sport ou dans la
compétition qu'elle comptait ses comptes
avec moi c'est quelque chose qui marche
comme je sais que du monde quand même
pourquoi ces gens le font soit je
comprendrais jamais moi je comme ces
gens là j'ai vu un couple on a toujours
mentionné retire le départ est à 7 ans
le matin et les gens jusqu'à minuit de
soi pour terminer la rhénane il ya
quelques check point voici maintenant du
passé check point en arrière d'un
certain temps ils sortent à manas
ça se peut très bien mais je sais
maintenant de 7 heures le matin à 7
heures le soir c'est des athlètes c'est
extraordinaire de 6 7 ans le soir à
minuit là c'est déjà le monde ce domaine
il le la misère humaine mais à travers
le nuage de monde qui souffrent il ya
des pères et je veux toujours me
souvenir un couple de deux personnes qui
décroise henri jammet qui dit ceci des
rognons fédrun jamais team ait eu le
saut et aux lèves marcher main dans la
main de bonne humeur ils sont combien on
va le finir on prend le temps ils
marchent ensemble terme c'est désarmant
oui de beauté et de ses grandioses et
ulti curieusement une seule personne il
ya plusieurs personnes qui ont été
disqualifiés pour une seule personne qui
ait terminé leur nuit à minuit une meute
ont craqué pas eu sa médaille c'est lui
qu'il belle arrivée à mende c'était le
tout le monde tels tout le monde tirait
pour lui huit moines étaient tellement
contents qu'il termine mais il n'y a pas
eu sa médaille mais y avait quelque
chose à être le fait l'histoire de
marathon de changements radicaux contre
castres et c'est georges laraque ie10 le
profil d'un court le marathon idyllique
où le couru en cinq ou six heures
séparant aux 300 livres et a320 mais il
y avait des crampes dit tout les coups
de poing que j'ai reçu de ma carrière de
joie dehors qui t'est combinant un coup
de poing
ça me fait moins mal que ce marathon de
10 du coût et quid des crampes et
difficile
totalement déshydratés les médecins ont
dit genre tout minutes plus tard tu
aurais pu mourir le thé
sauf que lui en cliquant ici je le
termine
il termine ses puis il ya vraiment
quelque chose de l'entraînement pour un
rendement un entraînement physique t au
incroyable soit des mesures des mesures
et discipliné face à chaque jour du bac
de natation mais l'entraînement mental
que ça prend la force mentale c'est
encore plus important à chambre en point
ces gens là les pc que j'aimerais
tellement ceux offerts un way commencer
par la mère attentive et et pendant mon
moi sans alcool cette année j'ai fait
mon sac février de tactique et physique
à chaque jour un minimum 15 minutes
d'activité physique par jour ça finit
par être écouté sur 28 jours je pense
j'ai fait déjà 25 jours de grosse
traînée puis trois jours de plus légers
dont une de ces journées le gère pas le
temps de rien faire en fait juste âgée
juste j'ai couru pour aller chercher mon
café je veux toujours faire du jogging
ce matin quinze mille et un terminal de
toutes les techniques de mon moi c'est
celui que j'ai fait ce qu'il m'a fait
tellement longtemps j'avais couru je
suis parti pis mon seul ma seule
motivation c'était juste 15 minutes
la première minute et gambien a great ça
va après une minute quand j'ai jamais
couru à mon pot aujourd'hui d'adulte
j'ai couru quand j'étais ado tu sais
quand tu coupes support puis comme des
des justes un enfant mais aujourd'hui
quand même si je suis pourtant pas un
ton jeu pèse comme entre 185 et 190
livres s'est jamais pesé ce et le courir
excentrique en a mieux c'est dur
j'écoutais et désordre qui en a fait une
car combien parce que il ya fait le
comme un marathon en 50 jours ouais
singe sans aucun training c'est un
malade mais lui ai fait un peu en charge
de l'art à gaver m moi je le fais c'est
tout bonne question de le faire vite
qu'une question de performer c'est juste
je me mets des filles vraiment difficile
à atteindre mais je l'attend mais la
journée où tu le fais
la puissance qui ressort de ce que le
feeling que tu apprends vrai bon gros
training la douche après ou mais quand
tu es dedans c'est l'enfer mais après ça
que je peux même pas imaginer le
sentiment que dans ce sens à redman ses
seules ses seuls feeling cc c'est ce
qu'on recherche c'est ce que c'est cette
bulle il ya des sciences défier le monde
qu'ils disent mais ton va monter
j'aime pas faut y aller m'entraîner il
n'y a pas beaucoup de monde qui adore ce
pendant l'entraînement l'été la
souffrance des autres en natation mais
je me rappelle pote d'une pratique oui
c'est comme tu es en train de payer
comme un sale état c'est l'autre
roquette a envie de vomir mais mais la
mine que c'est fini la seconde c'est
fini le sentiment que tu que tu ville
que tu reçois tout l'endorphine ses best
thing i mais le pire c'est que c'est là
où tu vois que ceux qui aiment ce camp
c'est off ils se rendent wathier oui je
vous l'avais entendu l'histoire c'est
mon avis des bocages qui était manager
qui m'avait compter ce même francis
bouillon dans takjout et il y avait je
pense enfin exprès y avait cassé le nez
je dirais tu continues ou sky avait gelé
ovechkin d'en face lloris qui s'était
blessé puis avec omar placer ce vite sur
le banc et avait continué à jouer vite
et comme caen
quand le peuple et surtout six joueurs
d'hervé scanner crosby en espèce de
respect ou bouillon en fait un agent
retourner le voir parce que j'ai faim
d'amour j'ai fait comme je regardais
gates frigara du week end comme nos
chiffres que servette y croient
nos chiffres qui rentrent il faut que
j'imagine qu'ils foutent angel le
processus également aussi aussi le
processus
autant le processus que la fin du mois
mais métier ça prend du temps mais le
processus nécessaire parce que
ce qui m'a plu plus t'en fais plus ça
passe vite ouais si tu me donne
l'exemple en 15 minutes le 15 minutes
c'est normal que ce soit long c'est la
première fois que tu cours at-on
poitiers mais à force d'en faire tout ça
devient rien - non ça devient quelque
peu après ces deux heures c'est qu'elle
est plus et plus tu en fais même si
c'est long le selor ce long processus
mais tu veux quand même temps mon moi
sans alcool litigieuses est super
longtemps je m'entraîne le plus quand
même un grand fond mais je peux jeu
discipliné pour le training comme je
veux m'entraîner 5,6 x semaine des fois
c'est avec grand plaisir j'aime ce que
sait pas c'est pas une tâche pour moi
garou jim et moi logement que disent ils
c'est vrai cela la nourriture the gates
of c'est ce qu'ils disent entraînements
c'est le but le fun des mots car j'étais
tout le temps sus de l'entraînement si
ce qu'ils font est fiancée ne pas sortir
le vendredi soir ce qui est chiant c'est
de jamais prendre une bière relaxe le
soir de ce qui est chiant c'est de faire
attention à tout ce que tu manges c'est
ce que le chien mais ce qui est six et
la journée ou ce que tu traverses et ce
comme n'importe quoi tu sais comme quand
tu passes sur une des rares le paren
coupe deux autres cochons super tendu ça
beaucoup tu bois tu fais pas ci fais ça
peut être qu'ils jouent bien puisqu'ils
commencent à tout moment sans arrêt cet
essai c'est que l'escale et attache moi
pas et à tous les jours je dois faire du
sport fait comme à nice comme si je sais
que demain j'ai de quoi
de 10h à bien chaud le soir puis je
quitte la journée mais faut que je me
lève à 8 ans que je m'entraîne j'ai pas
le choix c'est je me suis dit que
j'allais enfin il avait mais tu fais
attention tu que je plutôt du style est
plutôt tu le fais mes mots - sans alcool
curieusement ça m'a aidé à traverser
comme une espèce de deux plateaux ce
qu'ils achetaient panier depuis très
longtemps et léger attinger juste
débloquer sur pleine affaire femme homme
engagé
j'ai atteint des poids que avec certains
exercices que j'avais
j'avais jamais atteint j'attends une
endurance que j'avais pas facile
tellement le fun de traverser ce moment
là la faire par contre je sais pas vous
avez does it et non j 10 mai d'enfants
sekurit avoir parce que j'ai pas du tout
compétitionner au niveau auquel vous
avez compétitionner mais où est-ce que
vous retourner chercher cette adrénaline
là dans votre vie aujourd'hui thé
comme il ya quelque chose de grisant la
compétition surtout rendu à l'âge adulte
témoin j'ai lâché look et quand ça
devenait grand tshitshi quand ça
devenait 8 et j'ai jamais vraiment connu
du vrai bois qui est compétitif oui le
mais je ne sais pas par effet qu'à l'âge
adulte quand tes cartes étaient 22,8
compétition la jeune star est qu est-ce
qu est-ce qui est ce que c'est un manque
dans vos vies est ce que c'est ça s'est
transformé
où est ce qu est ce que vous allez
chercher ça aux contrastes de comment
j'allais vécu chez rhodia way béton mais
d après moi quand j'ai arrêté la
natation
j'avais un plan je savais exactement par
quoi ce village allait combler puis je
pense que ça a été super important parce
qu'il y en a beaucoup justement qui est
aujourd hui arrête c'est comme ça fesse
che mat le savent pas trop quoi faire
ils le il ya un vide dans leur ville et
puis moi dans le fond j'ai arrêté où
j'ai arrêté ça fait longtemps ça fait
dix ans que je jardine orge et j'arrête
après secondaire honte en sport études
ensemble et moi je savais que j'allais
rentrer en musique au cégep
puis je faisais un peu de musique
métissée pas tant que sur le jeu des
points enfant prodige des portes et jimi
hendrix 15h10
sauf que je savais que si je le fasse
dans la vie falloir que je mette
beaucoup de discipline de travail de
sérieux la rigueur puisque je l'avais
dans la natation je l'avais ce parce
qu'ils vont s'entraîner deux fois
semaine à 115 matin souvent très pipi
ccsn vie c'était une vie de discipline
pilot quand je rentre au cégep je
participe à rentrer première session je
t'ai pas le king de l'école je n'ai pas
lu qing de guitare sauf que rapidement
la discipline que j'avais atteint 10
avec la natation bain rapidement et j'ai
rattrapé le troupeau et ses pieds même
je n'ai dépassé une coupe parce que
c'est autant qu'au secondaire de la
guitare
autant pour tenter on se lève dans cinq
ans c'est aujourd'hui le
j'ai pu la haye de la rigueur parce que
l'être j'ai fait les sprints le tg fait
le comme le bootcamp universités
maintenant aussi j'ai découvert que
l'envi ya beaucoup de choses qui sont
intéressants comme fallait pas de cave
comme tu es type i had come & stay à
l'époque composée que le les années que
je me suis enfermé à faire une et une
seule chose ça a été la meilleure
décision que j'ai prise l'a vite parce
que quand j'étais au cégep mettons je me
levais à ccnmi set prenant un bus selon
gervais à l'école habite qui géra meco
et donc j'avais dépose même des pauses
de 10 minutes en décourageant de la
guide les midis jouer de la guitare
manger à ma faim matches le soir qu'elle
est cofinancé mettons que ce soit 3 4 ou
5 je restais jusqu'à 9 au cégep
parce que je prenais le bus à 9 et 20
gervais chinois disent je me couchais
puis partait déjà des fois des fois je
rentrais été la porte à porte au sol
toujours pour toutes les animations
puis quand tu rentres et bitumes et ont
peu trop fort mais n'a jamais tant la
mère de thomas nous voyait piste est
même pas sûr que ce fait ça allait mais
je me rappelle des fois je rentrais le 2
mai tendre à la fois rock du début du
tout caricatural mais dont il fait des
gammes médecins pratiquent des trucs
puis là on tue un peu quand je repartais
surprendre sa get pitié aujourd'hui mais
tant pis je suis l'actualité je
m'informe je litige sur la fin et
pendant ces années le savez je resterai
pas dite et qu'il maire de montréal
sauf que ce ça m'a donné ce qui
maintenant d'autres choses que j'ai
trouvé que tel aspect de gagne de
natation l'aspect des tarifs d'un coach
qui qui force à aller plus loin
le fait deux ans je commençais crossfit
les gens retrouvent ce soir là que se
tient le crossfit notre fac et la
plainte
beaucoup vont dire que c'est pour
mettons le cep d'entraînement optimales
c'est aussi un super beau critiquer mais
c'est moi je vois un poste lui-même
passé c'est l'idée l'idée c'est arrive
là tu t'engages dépasser mais la verve
du crossfit
mais j'en ai fait un genre de 11 12 13
il ya quelque chose de tellement la
communauté du croate est tellement forte
c'est tellement sain c'est tellement le
fun comme vibe que c'est comme quand
même tarif pour finir un award car
depuis que ceux qui ont fini
t'encourager quelque chose de super
positive ce qui comprend les gens qui
critiquent mais je pensais juste d'être
prudents ou de crossfit jeu n'importe
quelle forme de training à son backlash
si j'osais faire beaucoup de poids au
bac squats c'est négatif
oui mais c'est en fait juste une rue
d'assas et faut faire attention tout le
temps aucun suspense qui durcissent et
que ça prend vraiment une bonne
technique pour faire certains workout
paquet mais après ce que j'ai c'est moi
j'ai adoré faire ça c'est juste
qu'aujourd'hui je peux plus c'est trop
brûlant pour faire face à la nati que je
peux pas faire un traînée de quoi si tu
es un show la même journée c'est sûr que
je lis un des deux qui va écoper
je peux pas je peux maintenant je suis
rendu à un point où j'ai assez d'énergie
pour faire des gros training puis un
gros show de ce soir là cela facile mais
ça m'est arrivé les fois de partir de
jim pour aller direct shopi jeu comme en
corse la vrine j'aime ça va bien pour
dire que ce soit la natation la guitare
ou le crossfit c'est le plaisir c'est
quand que tu mais si le vol est résulté
de ton travail vaut l'admiration pis si
la pratique d'exercices physiques puis
je les quitte à ce que les activités
différentes mais pas tant que ça dans ce
sens que ces bêtes travail petite voix
résulte de l'amélioration puis à chaque
jour selon greenpeace continue continue
puis moi je pense que la clé du succès
souvent le problème à l'entraînement ou
le premier à atteindre ses objectifs
c'est maintenant le manque de motivation
sauf que la motivation c'est comme un
peu
un ami sur lesquels on peut pas ce fils
parce que le twitter
et pour motiver sa tante pop hits c'est
quand même un cercle vicieux souvent que
tu fais tu le fais rien s'attend pas
encore moins y planter c'est le
commitment c'est juste du comité quelque
chose puis 10 peu un pascal riou g pas
choix dans le forum pour ce téléthon 30
jours sans alcool ou 28 jours sans
alcool c'est le commitment que tu dis
que tu es obligé de le frapper en plus
tout à fait la bonne affaire moi j'avais
fait la même chose dans le mois de
janvier
tu l'annoncé non puis ceux moins
d'annoncer ses objectifs c'est quelque
chose que tu apprécies tu es obligé de
rendre des comptes
ouais puis si tu es obligé de rendre des
comptes il y avait un coach l'équipe
canadienne de natation qui disait que ça
va pas de tente et 33 % du temps fait
qu'un tiers des entraînements ça
tenterait pas d'y aller avec deux fois
sur trois tu vas y aller salle comtale
l'autre fois votre petite botte le cul
pour élever le puits si tu es obligé de
rendez compte
ça va te forcer à faire ce pays tu sais
c'est un peu seul but ce que moi je
manque maintenant c'est un coach oui le
coach qui sait que livrer clé un chèque
d'un compte à rendre à cette personne-là
puis même si c'est pas l'âme si ça doit
pas être ta motivation initiale
ça ne sert dans le tiers que c'est un
conte en danger les quinze ans j'ai créé
h au secondaire le les entraînements
5h30 le matin avant d'aller à l'école ça
ne m'a pas tenter une institution matin
que je bidouille et st est un fait des
centaines que ce réveil 10 à se
réveiller ça a été facile qui était
comme yes je m'en vais m'entraîner
sauf que c'est toujours le wii ware
après avoir fait c'est surtout qu'est ce
tu vois si ivo fait ramasser par ton
corps aussi 30 ans gary fico
mais les autres sont levés qui ont vu
que tous les avoirs et les autres tes
amis tes coéquipiers lui qui voit que tu
te lèves pas telle est trou d'cul que
c'est pas vrai a dit m fac
j'imagine qu'un truc pour quelqu'un qui
la misère à se motiver ses troupes dans
la journée quand les deux envie de
choquer mais l'autre les craintes cinq
ensembles ou juste
ouvrant des comptes ou juste te dire
l'histoire commitment que je prends peu
importe car ivoire je le fais quelque
chose de très puissant aussi ne
serait-ce que même dans ville c'est bon
juste d'écrire des objectifs des fossati
moi je maman m'avait sorti la feuille
sur laquelle j'avais écrit en 2012 je
rêve d'avoir mon one-man-show à même de
sortir la géologie faire le semble j'ai
sorti mais c'est vous dire ça va arriver
et y mais des fois il a passé six de
leurs maîtres justement fait rage je
vais marcher trois fois par semaine
juste de le faire cesser la famille
évidemment que la motivation est dure
mais et c'est tellement important je
trouve ça super important comme mais ça
me désole de voir des gens des fois
qu'ils prennent pas soin deux types à
50,26 primordial c'est la première fois
où ça et tout c'est moi j'ai été un lieu
qui sort tout cas j'étais d'abord
beaucoup le titre de 2013 à 2017
j'animais d'un bar se faisaient des
shows du monde dans les bars tous les
soirs on se faisait payer 25 pièces avec
deux consommations planète reach avec le
staff lyonnais on ajoute à mon époque tu
sais que je t'aime je n'ai jamais arrêté
de m'entraîner complètement mais j'étais
vraiment moins en forme je faisais mon
attention - curieusement la journée je
me suis mis à être vraiment occupé c'est
la journée je me soumets at plus
m'entraîner parce que je t'aime c'est
trop important joué à sa tension avant
je suis le rythme puis aujourd'hui mon
début adna tourner surtout c'est
impossible
c'était comme dans ma tête je me fasse
une sieste avant chaque jour j'ai pas le
choix
puis aujourd'hui j'en fais pratiquement
plus sauf si vraiment je me suis levé
tôt on a fait beaucoup de route
merci torse et le jim me réveille si je
fais de la route c'est la prof encore y
est naissance des seins baie comeau a
après huit heures de route 9 heures de
route on arrive et on drapeau james et
ce qui me réveille puis souvent gentil
justin 20 minutes de deux petites pièces
pour me réveiller
puis le voir avec je suis rendu meilleur
au jam c'est comme plus fort dans ma
tête j'ai le goût d'y aller à tous les
jours quand je vais pas ça veut dire oui
des fois évidemment c'est bénéfique pour
le corps mais surtout le goût d'y aller
par et puis j'ai plus d'énergie
je suis plus en forme je dors mieux je
fais des meilleurs shows j'ai plus du
des jeux plus clair c'est lui le plus de
bonnes marges plus comme
il ya tellement de bien fait j'ai le
goût de mieux manger comme tout suit
souvent souvent les lits cercle vicieux
de dépression commence par ceux où est
ce que l'autre forme dans un patelin est
ce qu'il a à l'autre ce matin-là satan -
puis le témoin actif et au moins
d'énergie s'est plu à relever ployer -
raison de te lever plus de temps dans un
cercle qui ça c'est vraiment une façon
de réguler et de clarifier l'esprit j'ai
l'impression d'avoir un district ou du
moins juste d'avoir un routine qui
permet de rester debout j'ai d'être
actif absolue où curieusement tous les
gens occupés soit c'est les gens qui
prennent le petit mot souvent c'est ce
qui est arrivé là c'est que je me suis
mis et je me souviens le mot je me suis
mis à faire vraiment attention c'est en
en juillet je faisais 40 chaud dans le
mois moi je perds ma voix vraiment
facilement quand je fatigue et jeux
comme j'ai pas le choix de faire
attention à quantité d accueil que je
bois laura que je me couche
c'est ce que je fais les trainings faut
que je fasse attention faisant partie
site et j'ai vraiment j'ai fait
attention dans ce moule puis le ca ca
fait quelque chose qui crie jamais du
père plus la voix depuis ce temps là ou
presque passer ses nerfs
c'est fou tantôt tutu poser la question
c'est par rapport à l'adrénaline ou
est-ce qu'on retrouve en adrénaline
après être moi j'ai continué à nager
après quelques uns de m'arrêter puis je
suis comme tomber dans un mettons cache
quand j'allais au championnat canadien
universitaire puisque le jouer c'est
pour gagner par exemple où cette espèce
de rush le jeu l'est pas encore retrouvé
j'ai pas ça manque énormément
ouais énormément il ya quand même toutes
les circuits de natation universitaire
ou est ce que c'est un équipe est en
équipe vit l'homme
quand tu vois tes gosses bape quelqu'un
de marianne2 le des carabins mettons
l'université morial peu tout le monde et
est trop pomper plus tu as toi d'y aller
après puis chaque chaque personne a un
rôle c'est moi je moi je gagnais mais
mon rôle était pas nécessairement plus
important que celui qui arrivé septième
ou huitième parce que tout les points
contre happy tout le monde et il est
trop excité puis ça
je je pense pas que je vais à gabat de
retrouver ça c'est comme un feeling qui
va faire faut que j'imagine que je
tourne la page que je laisse derrière
parce que c'était trop intense et s est
vraiment quelque chose de quelque chose
d'unique vraiment le type l'heure
j'essaie dé foi des formes et oncle j'ai
couru le marathon les bijoux des courses
organisées
quant au talent et au chapitre des
maîtres nageurs l'année prochaine si je
sais leur trouver des trucs comme ça
mais j'ai l'impression que rien que moi
même s'approcher de cette dose complète
de d'adrénaline mais qu'est ce que c'est
comme dom il a appris quelque chose de
ce thème destin pendant sa vie qu'il a
menée dans sa vie actuelle toilettes ou
quelque chose de ce que tu as menée
notamment s'il ya quelque chose que j'ai
appris le sais pas peut pas besoin
d'avoir un gros twin à chaque jour de
besoin d'avoir dix bons training à
jacter ans chaque jour c'est pas c'est
pas une question c'est pas un sprint
le pi dans ma carrière c'était ça
c'était c'était un sprint et se soit
blessé ou bernard puis j'ai l'impression
que c'est la même chose ça même le même
truc que j'ai appliqué ma vie maintenant
c'est de dire il n'y a rien qui est un
sprint tout et pour le longue le l'oncle
et le long granby puis en ce moment je
voudrais je m'entraîne pas pour demain
matin et faire un dix kilos fu king vite
je m'entraîne pour que quand je vois est
rendu à 40 un choix en chef est encore
capable de le faire
puis c'est pas mettons mettons que
demain matin ou à soi antho après
podcast de ciment vos jeans que je fais
un esti burkhalter un genre de 21 kg de
course avec des intervalles que je me
des choses serait capable de le faire
une fois demain matin je dois me lever
puis je veux pas aller m'entraîner
non je le sais je sais que ça va arriver
parce que je veux être trop défoncé
puisque j'ai appris je pense parce que
dans ma carrière c'était souvent souvent
cas qu'on avait un gros traîné avant
quand je m'entraînais mettons plus
jeunes avant que j'apprenne cette nuance
la tête d'un gros training journée le
lendemain tu ne lâches
chier pendant deux jours avant que tes
entraînements serve à quelque chose fait
que tu parles tout ce que tu viennes
fort en tête dans ton gros twinning ce
j'ai appris sur le tard à l'intérieur
puis la constance
puis c'est de trouver aussi je pense
tout ce que tu dis aussi des fois les
gens vont faire corps afin que vous je
pousse - puis comme nom team s'est
trouvée c'est quoi ta ligne toi quoi la
zone exacte
maintenant moi je sais que je pratique
un peu ce que tu dis mais un niveau
qu'ils jouent pas comme juste quelqu'un
normal assez élevé quelqu'un d'actif
vous exactement la moyenne définitive
est sorti mais mais moi je l ai
tellement à j'ai longtemps mais pas
longtemps lemay était pressé surtout
quand j'ai commencé à limoges les
principes de réussir les buts prince et
de faut que ça marche et si oui comment
la journée où on dit mais tu me quittes
je réalise que hg mais quitte depuis le
début j'étais en train de faire c'est
déjà temps plein c'est ce qui se faisait
si je faisais déjà j'étais déjà heureux
de france et je suis devenu ambitieux le
matin est ambitieux ccfi ra mathon est
exact où on est des kits
on va écouter le podcast l'eau ne serait
ce que dans un an pour enfants méfiait
studite pis tant mieux tant mieux mais
si une des enfants qui me faisaient de
plus stressés maintenant de tp mon show
c'est que la gelée capter ce tellement à
stx tech
j'étais nerveuse des semaines de davon
taipei le jour j comme c'est tellement
un art vivant le stand-up que c'est
comme d'un soir à l'autre
audrey qu'à chaque fois je faisais un
christ de bonnes choses débarquer
cependant ça marche c'est comment on a
dit ça va être ça date le foot ils sont
peut-être pas c'est d'avoir pu la merde
mais c'est ce qui est assez de faire je
sais que la journée je vais le sortir
tout est rendu ailleurs je vais
travailleurs puissent voir plus clair
seppi c'est que comme il dit et de mes
amis qui ne s'est pas trompé sur le post
canon ça m'aidera pas qu'aux seuls
grands et de chromite que tu allais
sortir sans le faut je le sors déjà fort
je l'aï ce pour que le deuxième je l
adore qu'il à genoux lui je sortais je
laisse la troisième
le but c'est qu'ils peuvent dès
maintenant je sais pas si vous dans vos
milieux aujourd'hui dans ta musique en
podcast dans ce que vous faites des fois
j'ai l'impression que des fois j'ai
senti que des personnes par john
vraiment un petit pourcentage de la main
des personnes qui les critiquent à un
point où c'est même plus constructive
c'est juste tu devrais pas faire ce
d'avis et puis moi ce niveau là je
trouve ça comme méchant blessant puis
après si je dois faire un mon but est
plus grand que dans son premier one man
show ici c'est le mieux que je pouvais
s'offrir un dieu mes capacités
j'écris sur le 23 et 27 ans c'est le bes
que je peux t'offrir aujourd'hui mais le
but c'est pas de ma mère m'avait dit
c'est peut-être que je radote puis
l'avait dit dans les podcasts c'est vrai
mais maman moi l'école de l'humour staff
je trouve ça dur mes meilleures amies
str4 levac mais du bout c'est dense en
breton des gens hilarant alors ceux
travaillant tellement fort et moi j'ai
jamais été le meilleur j'ai été bon j'ai
un certain talent je travaille fort mais
la meilleure chose m'est avis que j'ai
jamais été le meilleur dans rien qui
fait en sorte que j'ai toujours couru
après la meilleure paire si c'est tough
est premier et deuxième c'est nice en
crise parce que c est qu après j'ai
toujours une petite gueule ça que j'ai
toujours travaillé très forte
puis moi je me souviens la tournée de
l'école de l'humour j'ouvrais la tournée
state of mon numéro est pas super bon
j'avais juste cinq minutes
c'était vraiment difficile et puis maman
m'avait dit et comme je veux pas écrire
ton meilleur numéro à 21 h m c'est
logique comme le but et plus grands le
but sidate le meilleur stand up possible
au au bout de ma vie tu es devant c'est
tout le temps filait juste toujours
repoussé les limites pc est déjà forte
et puis c'est ce qui est le fun c'est
matin hier j'ai essayé un nouveau but où
l'idée moi me fait rire mais c'est un
product puis je sentais que j'allais au
ces mais jeter comme un christ veut
l'avoir abandonnée je sais que c'est
juste tellement intéressant mais des
fois c'est dur d'être ambitieux d'être
l'acte iii reprend non tant team usa 6
hectares en fait l'année passée avec je
veux savoir le faire quand même troppo
santé l'étude enfin insisté guy leur
meute on arrive quand on a 35 ans
vous savez être encore phoque mjn ça va
être tout ça je sors plus d'expérience
je sais mais il ya de place avec 6,8
comment la journée ou ce qui est
maintenant j'ai lancé mon choix est fait
je peux prendre mon temps je peux je
peux prendre des vacances peut voyager
je peux vivre des affaires parce que
manager en plus si vous aussi faire des
podcasts aussi notre job c'est de parler
de ma nes et comme je sais la première
fois j'ai fait une heure ça prend fin de
ma vie je me pose la question pourquoi
je rencontre et se les gens m'offre une
heure de leur vie pendant une heure ils
font le choix de se taire et m'écouter
qu'est ce que j'ai à dire de si
intéressant pour que je devais mérite
cette attention aux pratiques puis je
pense pas que j'ai atteint les billets
sont disponibles sur tout mais ceci dit
il ya quand même quelque chose de 2,2
puis simple de fort la dent d'apprendre
de type de format qui était prendre son
temps mais de repousser ses propres
limites bien faire ici
la seule question qui se pose c'est si
tu de renforcer ou non c'est sa 38ème
juste que tu fais parce qu'après ce
temps parce qu'il veut et puis les gens
vont décider s'ils ont envie de venir te
voir non complètement famille apprécie
aussi tu vois je te répond céline dion
qui avec gux spi j'ai capoté
on vient voter mais comme un point le
j'ai été émue j'étais inspiré puisqu'il
m'a fasciné c'est de faire justement un
guest qu'en début de carrière c'est
l'annoncé faite car il est ici au québec
le moule mal tellement grind est
tellement travaillé fort tellement pas
lâcher le morceau de prononcer leur je
m'en veux je m'envole loin comme givel
et crise le prouveront tout le monde
parce que moi j'ai fait énormément de
sacrifices très très fort évidemment
qu'elle arrête à la maladrerie très fort
imagine aujourd'hui je me disais ça
vingtaine à dire sur le sujet dit tantôt
ph c'est comme s'ils te dire dans 20 ans
est temps de prendre avant le vendredi
soir sera temps de veiller s'attendre
visa forte quand tu le fais pas des fous
de ça que tu passes à côté quelque chose
mais je
je me suis vraiment dit en la regardant
je suis à doit vraiment être heureuse
aujourd'hui probable fort probablement
que d'être très heureuse
puis à quelque chose me sentir accompli
beaucoup moins et puis il ya quelque
chose c'est tellement dur je faisais ma
job est pas difficile à et humoriste un
hostie de luxe les genres on s'entend
mais il ya quelque chose de difficile si
oui tu trouves à l'âge adulte de vivre
la honte c'est pas quelque chose qu'on
vit beaucoup et on vit ce gène commencé
comme passe on est vite sauté et quand
tu fais de l'humour c'est sûr tu vas
vivre une soirée qui marchent pas c'est
automatique
automatique tu vas vivre un peu de lui
même le pire sentiment s'il sait que tu
étais si tu essayais de quoi et les gens
été témoin d'un échec et le dégel et à
personne doute ces diplomates et où ses
amis s'est fait virer n'étant pas viable
surtout quand tu essayes fort pitt et
chez toi échoué fars mais enfin de quoi
de vraiment puissant là dedans parce que
tu apprends beaucoup puis ça t'apprend à
temps c'est ton ego bien essayé père
pouces et est limité fait qu'il ya
quelque chose de super bon là dedans
curieusement si mais c'est là où tu
réalises que fo com vraiment se détacher
du regard littéralement de tout le monde
est concentré sur doit quitter vichy là
toi tu es moi je sais que la raison pour
laquelle je fais ce jeu c'est parce que
j'ai envie de refuser mes propres
limites
j'ai envie de mieux me connaître j'ai
envie d'être capable de transmettre une
émotion au monde
c'est souvent animaux encore plus que
les autres os tout ça s'arrose
on sent beaucoup passé via le public
parce que oui on a testé un dialogue le
public fait intégralement partie de mon
corps j'ai pas le choix mais ça reste un
art complet mais glisse comme si
comblement juste pour moi je le fais
j'aime trouver de nouvelles idées j'aime
trouver des nouvelles jo que j'aime
repousser mes propres limites parce
qu'il ya quelque chose de super
c'est vraiment spécial c'est l'eau en
voyant ces lignes j'étais comme inspirée
de faire comme je pensais pas finir à
temps c'est là notre grand totalement
inspiré avant ammann you do you et se
concentre sur des choses puis ça va bien
aller était ok puis moi c'est là où mes
enfants sont mis à bien des qualités ans
au début du podcast été
les entrevues me tente faisait ça au dès
ma première gates elista ma tv
c'est un show d'entrevue j'ai appris sur
le top je les fait plus mais je me suis
mis à bosser dessus c'est une chose que
tu es à vélo urbain des phoques est fort
mais je me rappelle c'est en écoutant
les émissions daudet ben ali quand j'ai
quand j'écoutais pour la première fois
les chauds puis on avait on avait notre
caractère parce que toi tu me parle à
moi piste elle c'est le seul qui a été
longue
- c'est le signe est idiot comme 30
minutes
à oui on avait en effet fait j'exagère
vraiment fait plus que ça on l'avait
fait aux tic ardennes ou deux ans m je
voudrais en temps réel on avait en effet
tautou 45 il faisait chaud soleil
d'enfance ont sué comme des paons mais à
t il était vraiment plus long que toutes
les autres pays moi je me rappelle je me
rappelle avoir eu le feeling était bon
un christ pour faire son intelligente
ici parce que parce tu avais tu avais
une oreillette en plus effectué dehors
du monde qui parlait dans ton oreille tu
sais je sais pas si commun mais tu dois
avoir du monde qui essayait de diriger
un peu la diction wever mais mais tu
étais quand même famille attentif à ce
que je te disais tu regardes de diriger
ce pays mais j'ai trouvé que c'était là
maintenant dans toutes les missions
d'aude et j'ai trouvé que c'est d'un
coeur à choeur prêtent particulièrement
bien parce qu'il était plus long peut on
voyait plus l'étendue de la pression
même les autres eux même en temps de
tournage ils m'ont monde partait 20
minutes puis après c'était fini
ouais mais mais moi j'ai trouvé que
c'est là que tu es le meilleur denjean
tour des nôtres l'animation dos des
pipits tu leur prouver après le succès
sur en quelque chose dans lequel tu
excelles me trouvais que c'était le
passage vraiment le plus humain de
l'émission se dit pit était vraiment une
captive capacité d'empathie je pense
pitié je me suis je pense ammaniti
parlant karine piste ali dit quand même
toit le blues avec hommes à bord d un
peu son besoin d'attention pour ce
piteux de réussi à lui faire comme
réalité les choses comprendre les choses
ou
je sais pas si il ya vraiment quelque
chose qui s'est passé là je trouve ce
crime il ya vraiment du tactile et du
talent pour comprendre quelqu'un puis
lui faire un peu j'ai remis quelque
chose de raté gens ça permettait aussi
de je trouve je trouvais de d'humaniser
un petit peu les personnes parce qu'on
sait à quel point ma part par la nature
de l'émission par le fric et du montage
que ça prend une ligne directrice
quel point les participants peuvent ne
pas être humain et aux yeux du public
réel peuvent être une caricature de la
personne puis ça je trouvais que ça
permettait vraiment d'aller nuance est
resté seul le point départ l'idée
c'était ce c'était puis moi je me
souviens qu'il m'avait dit tu vas voir
les entrevues et moi c'est sam sam était
au bout de ce thème à c'est ce que je
veux je voulais humaniser les gens pour
justement faire des fois c'est normal
que tout le monde comprenne pas
nécessairement les réactions des autres
mais quand tu comprend d'où la personne
vient tu peux avoir plus d'empathie pour
cette version est donc comprendre
pourquoi les 6 réactions le puil affaire
que je trouvais plate parce que je
comprenais c'est que on n'avait pas ce
temps d'antenne pour faire une bonne
grosse entrevue du nord qui candidats
chose que je comprends pas qu'il n'y a
pas trop petit mais je trouvais quand
même qu'ils avaient et ont passé un peu
à côté de quelque chose en allan poe ce
genre notre ville parce que j'étais
comme je pense pitié mais ton avec audi
grèce les 44 autres choses étaient plus
légiste de plus faux nez puisque ben
correct système imparfait puis il ya des
huttes il ya des candidats qui sont
réalisées des pires a déjà fait mais par
être humanisée mais je trouvais ça
intéressant de faire ce pipe à eau des
balles y mettons ça m'a pris du temps
leur fils morceau de tissu mais je
comprends pourquoi ça switcher de l'un
d'eux l'idée à posséder de partir
podcast pour conclure c'est peut-être
pas l'oxalys c'est bien car et c'est là
c'est ce que mais vous êtes bien fait
les garçons ont dit la vérité le podcast
vos peurs jouanno temps de montrer
qu'avec mais d'autres médias me dit
michael yee ya rejoint du monde accents
pas de casse auto citalis pop corn et
huawei extra ou considérant que je
rejoins du monde en tabarnak
oui ça drop et j'ai alors c'est ça le
fond ce que ce que l'on croit avoir
saisi mettons-les avec cette équipe si
on veut la blonde puis notre âge on sait
que il favorise énormément
la nouveauté fait si y'a comme des trend
un incident marque pas d'un nouvel trend
avec les nouveaux hashtag avec les
nouveaux nouvelles couleurs nouvelle
affaire comme ça ça se passera pas
vraiment le plus je me trouve des fois
vieux jeu excellent les choses changent
le sac à main mais bourges et à mieux
dans notre thèse évidemment on parle
d'instagram ça change ou quinze minutes
c'est même moi j'ai vu le ticket ont
changé les algues et les algorithmes
tubes comme ammann si j'ai plein de
following mais les gens non mais ça a
changé ma game pas je produisais motti
je produis mon choix même fashion comme
auch était oui je reprends le produit et
même quand je pose une photo tout le
monde à voir tous ces gens qui me
suivent la voie avec comme toujours
annoncer mon chou sar est parfait
changer l'algorithme annoncé comme tel
c'est tellement petit le pourcentage de
gens oui qui me suis dit voix mais
boselli on dirait que justement au
contrat ya de quoi de encore plus fort
j'ai l'impression quand tu t'en retire
tes dans l'absence des jantes on
remarque le t2 franchise précise aussi
plus le je sais pas j'ai comme un espèce
de terres 2020 je veux comme prendre des
vacances et puis une passe meilleur
parce que je ferme mon instinct
c'est justement à weggis lu j'ai fait
une mise à distance prendre des vidéos
de céline vise à avertir âge j'aurais
pas mon téléphone et je jouerai des
photos avant et pendant le show je veux
le voir je l'écouté je l'absorber 10e
puis seigneur d'avoir à se dire ça c'est
niaiseux de on est rendu là
l'aterrissage et des genres kany west
était au shoot séisme en même temps que
moi puis matthew du fan de kanye west
sa musique on parlera pas de sa matière
de police et je connais pour sa pige
projet j'y suis pas tant que cela mais
musicalement parlant most un budget en
rire énormément billetel plus j'étais
comme ça me fascine et le le le comme le
rapport aux femmes puisque comme à
gérald il ya pas grand monde qui me des
armes dans vie mais lui en fait
participé
il y avait quelque chose de bien pour
gagner l'équipe je me trouvais cru
évident pourquoi je regarde arrête de
regarder télé mais il y avait quelque
chose de juste vivre le moment je ne
sais pas il ya de quoi dans je pense que
justement l'intérieur les médias sociaux
team dans ma tête facebook est mort mais
doit mélanger des amis français que les
juments rythme temps c'est sur facebook
que ça se passe pour vous le dis je
pense à l'époque le monde qui avaient
déjà une tribune facebook c'est pas
nécessairement mais de partir une valeur
sûre tout avec une page facebook
ça a été la première chose c'est où ça
s'est mis à bien aller les premiers
shows j'ai rempli un premier 60 minutes
que j'ai fait mon 2014 au jack et je les
remplis vie mon facebook c'est comme ce
qui est arrêté pete wentz depuis
depuis 2007 j'ai recherché des trucs
mais j'ai rarement fait des trucs ce qui
se passe depuis cette année que facebook
ont acheté instagram c'est le même
principe qui est en train de se passer
sur instagram ce que du monde
mettons des commerces ou des artistes
qui étaient dépendantes facebook pour
vendre des trucs ils ont changé leur
guérite pour les pour qu'ils soient
obligés de payer pour atteindre le même
nombre de personnes pour qu'elles
fassent de l'argent public ceux qui
tenteraient de ces échanges mettons
quelqu'un qui tout au plus besoin
nécessairement instagram moralement pour
vendre des billets et il le monde
connaissent assez mais c'est encore
drôle il dit oui puis non
c'est ce qu'ils espèrent que moi
j'arrive afin d'en tourner aussi le thé
comme même si je finis en janvier au
centre bell il me reste juste vingt-cinq
jours ci le cc poule c très plus on
aurait fait au dessus d'eux ça le fait
que mais c'est là où je fais en début de
tournée oui si chaque homme je mettais
été les lions domaine
l'étoile dix30 g gens parlaient même
poste mais médias sociaux on ajoute une
supplémentaire ça se remplissent et
l'aujourd'hui là ça ralentit et les gens
qui voulaient me voir ils m'ont vu que
je commence à gratter plus le fauche
convaincre les fans jeu mais en plus les
gens vont non seulement le jeu sans que
ça ralentit mais j'ai tout en train
d'apprendre société c'est la première
fois je produis un chauve que je comme
je catch c'est le mois de juin par un
bon moment pour vendre ont cessé les
gens veulent aller dehors ils veulent
voir autre chose pisser je comprends
complètement mais moi ça me tente moins
d'y aller ces facs et c'est tout un
apprentissage mais c'est là où je pense
que c'est vous pensez que c'est quoi la
suite c'est que vous venez la prince
terrain quelque chose qu'ils voient
quelque chose qui vaut
qui va faire ce constat g faisait ça
veut dire le laisser la place aux
individus parce que maintenant mes tongs
pour continuer sur ce que je dit c'est
toi
admettons c'était 100% indépendant
d'instagram sera obligé de payer en soi
même
ce projet de payer pour avoir le même la
même portée survie de payer pour vendre
des trucs mais je pense qu est ce qui va
arriver c'est comme instagram est arrivé
ça va être de quoi qui laisse la place à
créativité que laisse la place l'unicité
des individus jusqu'à ce que facebook la
chine
mais peut-être que ce type de réseaux
sociaux le vont aussi se transformer
puis pas disparaître mais se modifier
type facebook c'est super cryptic que ça
veut dire mais utilisé que pour l'avenir
ça va en prendre une
une tournure vers le privé type ça va
être plus ça va être moins date et qui
met des choses pour le grand public
c'est plutôt mon pouvoir s'inviter fac
et je sais pas comment je sais pas
comment imaginer sam était peut-être les
réseaux sociaux est ce que tu poses de
quoi puis tout le monde le voit psy
c'est comme ça que ça fonctionne à
peut-être changé dit ouais mais c'est là
où j'ai commencé un cc loulé maintenant
le podcast je pars pour mon plaisir
personnel
mais je sais aussi que je pense à la
suite des choses que je pense à mon
deuxième chose c'est sûr et certain que
je sais des plateformes c'est maintenant
aux autres avec le studio sfr ont un
site web puis en fait au moment où est
le monde écoute ça on a un site web
saprophytes la vie est très vite puis ce
site web là il s'en ira jamais non
exacte et il veut le monde qui vont le
meilleur et pour le pire
c'est exact mais le monde qui vont aller
sur ce site là c'est notre plateforme
fait qu'on n'est pas sujet à aucun
algorithme on n'est pas sujet à aucun
changement dans la politique de
confidentialité ou un rêveur on est
sujet à rien fait avec toute la base de
fans qui ont créé autour de ceux qui ont
une notification quand un nouveau
podcast est en ligne
ça s'en va nulle part ils vont continuer
à la voir c'est quoi parce que c'est
nous qui créée sas et ses notes
youtube pour tourner avec des bâtons
dans les roues métier vraiment les
balados comme ça il faut que tu abonnés
à la chaîne sur ton téléphone
c'est l'heure je trouve ça fascinant
maintenant on commence on est dans les
extrêmes dit on a passé des genres
justement on est passé de vine au bois
de castres s'est défendu oui c'est là où
je pense qu'il ya beaucoup de choses qui
sont en réaction c'est justement
maintenant facebook mes enfants sont ma
poignée quand les gens disaient à ce qui
était intéressant sur facebook faut que
ce soit des petits des petits postes des
petits jobs bénéfique à ce que je
faisais des l'on pose c'est que marcher
je pourrais telus et la france elle
était médecin et je trouve souvent en
étendant les extrêmes s'est fait
convaincre curieux de voir parce que
instagram et ont moins au début j'ai
belle performance à mettre beaucoup ça
remplit mesalles c'est super le fun et
on dirait que le ch comme un peu je
déborde le titre super moche justement
je trouve que tout le monde ait rendu
font les mêmes enfants pitt
je suis pareil je rentre même affaire
parce que menez c'est comme être
inconsciemment ben si c'est cool je
pense puis je fais nous à limite drôle
de foot volley pataquès qui fonctionne
que je dépose que jade et des citations
inspirante a mené c'est comme si après
ça dépend ce que tu en fait il ya des
gens que c'est ça leur travail même si
parfait mendy quant à tous sa finalité
c'est instagram puis si ce ton métier
gaufres et et moi la phase finale
les tableaux dansants soumettons ces
monstres à g est là pour attirer les
gens dans martial la finalité c'est
d'amener le monde le final mais ce qu'on
voit c'est que faire il ya des gens pour
qui
instagram c'est cela un média l'arrêté
doit s'arrête là il n'y a pas de suivre
pour qui une fois d'autres moyens tout
ça c'est ce que tu es dans le temps des
fêtes juin
j'ai vraiment une journée tout le temps
des fêtes c'est comme tu arrives au afin
de l'annexer la rétrospective sur qu'est
ce qui vient d'être dit puis je me
rappelle je disposais les suspects sur
la mer puis j'ai juste appelé ma mère je
viens pas super g comme je suis vraiment
pas et je me suis juste loué une chambre
d'hôtel on était genre le
23 le sujet ce que l'internaute lg
appeler jessi et agissons par à côté de
l'hôtel que j'ai joué j'ai fait je fais
le pas pour nous asseoir la famille
excuses - ou prêtons pas prêtes mais on
se reparle demain puis pendant une
soirée complète juste remis en question
qu'est ce que je faisais pourquoi est ce
que malgré tout ce qui était autour de
moi malgré la vie que je menais qui
était d'apparence heureuse et enviable
j'imagine pour plusieurs personnes
pourquoi est-ce que je te prête d'être
100% heureux dans ce mécanisme la caisse
qui m'empêchait d'atteindre cette espèce
de bonheur le puits j'ai fait la g est
allé tout ce que je faisais qu'est ce
qui me rendait vraiment heureux puis le
podcast est vraiment un projet qui
motivait complètement puis instagram
comment gagner ma vie un peu avec ça en
faisant des pauses bien en jouant la
game que tu parlais de gomme tout le
monde est un peu coupable de participer
à ce monsieur dit ça ça me rend pas bien
j'ai pas bien de me battre pour rester
ouvert les veines dans l'algorithme
c'est parce qu'il faut que tu poses
foutu phase historique faut que tu te
comme une pression d'enfer pruneaux la
base pour rester là puissamment gossip
plaide me suis dit ok pas dedans je vais
arrêter de prendre des contres pour x y
jean gardé quelques-uns comme new
balance parce que je trouve c'est juste
fois king live ça prend un style de vie
sain et puis je rachète avec toi mais
sinon je vais juste parler du podcast je
m'en fous etc si vous voulez arrêter de
me suivre
arrêtez de me suivre je m'en fous ça ça
me tente pas d'être là tout le temps de
l'utiliser juste pour jouer à ce jeu le
puits depuis que j'effectue depuis le
temps des fêtes
ma vie après une coche au moins rien
vraiment peloton comme ce projet là en
plus du studio phi phi
depuis me soucier de rester des des
chiffres us et demie stats depuis avoir
cette espèce d'impressionner le juste
prendre ce qui me tente de force de
frappe aux causes pour le reste ça
vraiment changer complètement la donne
pour moi c'est mon fils c'est juste moi
avec des invités du ccg
rien de plus sain que faire le point
comme ceux des petits enfin pour la
liste maintenant que c'est que les
actions comme tu le fais tu sais que je
fais à chaque jour c'est parce que les
petits 15 minutes que tu fais ou les
petites actions répétées ça finit par un
site à 4 les additions cet avis y
mettant des pensionnats d'entrée fait
qu'à chaque jour bain et additionne se
pisser des années de ta vie qui part
d'un trafic anti tanks et des affaires
de même que ok ce soit ça me rassure oui
ou non puis ticket sa semaine ça peut
être questionné ta relation avec tomtom
tableau ses seins ou city est ce que
cette relation ne me rend heureux si
qu'est ce qu'ils meurent là dedans oui
c'est quoi qui est ce ce puits cette
affaire non est-ce que je peux
travailler jusqu'à publier risso depuis
seul à penser non b qui pourquoi puis
c'est toutes ces affaires le théâtre qui
leur importe la personne qui se réveille
quant à john patterson qui se réveille
dans vingt ans dans une vie campo
complètement jamais cette personne le
fait d'être lucide sur ses courts ma vie
en ce moment puisque à chaque jour je
vois la bonne direction
quelques elle jeudi chance mais ce n'est
pas de la chance mais de de réaliser sa
note gharbaoui c'est comme oui mais je
consulte depuis quelques temps tu es une
psy pis a m'a vraiment beaucoup
et puis je pleure pas tant sur le bureau
récemment c'est juste tellement le fun
de ce fait charlene jeep de nez dans une
pièce sans jugement de défaut d'arriver
le chargé de décharger leurs sorties et
puis je me pose une question justement
c'est ce qui est fascinant c'est que moi
aussi le temps des fêtes est un moment
de gros bilan type
sur ce coup là maintenant ton entourage
et respecter ton besoin de faire comme
principaux comptes vous autres c'est
pour moi a songé besoin de titre puis
des fois faut être égoïste pour être
plus généreux petits défauts faut
prendre du temps pour soi pour être bien
dans notre vie pauvre
après ce être 100% le pour son entourage
c'est pisser lahoud est faux comme
rééquilibrer la patente séville mais
c'est là où jusqu'à ce que tu as dit ça
m'a fait penser comme on y trouve ça me
fait toujours rire je pars de même si
j'ai l'impression d'être bien ce que
vous aimez ces clichés les yeux qui fige
qu'ensuite c'est comme les podcasts j'y
crois pas qu'un mec m'a demandé comme
c'est quoi ta quête en ce moment et
jusqu'à 1 à 7 ou être moi-même 1 km
exactement
et quelle magnifique quand et quelle
chance que d'avoir cette quête la 27 ans
que de réaliser ce 6 juillet puis nous
en plus on est chanceux parce qu on est
mené à cette époque que c'est mon
monsieur en dit surtout c'est souvent
des personnes plus vieille que mon père
a dit fais pas tout à ce que tu veux
dans ma vie comme crème j'ai
l'impression que je suis pas d'accord et
quelle chance
quelle chance que de que de me dire non
moi tous les jours enfin exactement ce
que je veux seppi des fois il faut je
fasse quelque chose qui comme fou comme
que tu fasses une erreur qu'un pote trop
que tu prennes un contre de trop pour
réalisé par thibaud si ça me rend folle
oui je vais me faire voir où j'en fais
de l'argent je rencontre mon trip en ont
rêvé mais qui sait pas ce qui me rend
rimouski malheureux c'est franck ntp des
podcasts courir ou wherever et hips et
comme dernièrement ça m'est arrivé de
petits moments d'angoissé enfin je n'ai
pris trop un peu que jamais temps je
parlais de podcasts mais au moins on est
sûr que le temps de partir pas de cash
comme doute ce succès pour moi c'est
important qu'elles fassent ça va me
faire du bien que ça va m'aider des
échanges comme monde en ce moment tu
sors de là énergisé recentrer et comme
tout brasse des idées justes dans ta
personne je trouve ça fascinant faqih
d'utiliser le temps des fêtes pour ça
c'est génial père précédée fois j'ai
fait d'entendre fois je me suis dit
qu'est ce que je peux le faire n'importe
quand ce bilan que je peux repartir à
zéro tout le temps je pourrai être parce
que j'ai envie d'être du jour au
lendemain c'est tout le temps tout le
temps tout le temps puis quand il est
des fois je dis oui à du monde moi aussi
j'ai commencé à faire des années qu'ils
vendaient christ est choqué son nom j'ai
pris du temps pour moi glg fait de
l'espace
excuse moi je t'avais dit oui je peux
pas cm je suis désolé c'est que là
j'avais j'avais cette conversation le
cette semaine avec jesse justement qui
est jack est un peu qu'est ce qu'est ce
qu'elle voulait faire puis il y avait il
y avait certaines de ses étés il y avait
six ans après trop de détails à
certaines et certains des trucs à
voulait faire qu'ils avaient un impact
sur nos trucs comme un puits qui pouvait
mettre à l'eau certains projets qu'on
avait ensemble moi j'ai dit si tu veux
faire ce que ça va prendre plus heureuse
je m'en crisse s'il faut quand c'est les
x ou y
parce que toi tu veux faire they do w je
manque ça me dérange pas je vais
préférer mille fois que tu fasses
quelque chose qui te rend heureuse au
détriment du matériel ou d'un projet qui
m'excite mais que si c'est parce que ça
va être autre chose voir occuper mon
temps tipi puis ça je pense que trop
souvent j'ai l'impression qu'on se met
la pression pour des trucs pour des
trucs matériel d'une certaine façon
l'espèce d'idées de détecter de gagner
sa vie au sens de nos grands parents
voici même la bouffe sa table tibi je
comprends je comprends mais si moi
j'avais pas les moyens en ce moment de
me payer un appart comme je me paye le
jeter dans un appart plus petits sauf
que si ce que je faisais me rendais plus
heureux mais je serai correct de farce
il demande maintenant il ya une espèce
de tendance et qui s'appelle saint paul
les ving ces deux mondes qui deviennent
ultra minimaliste pitt le vans life le
danois la seule longueur ça mais c'est
un peu
le thé l'archétype même dé sûr c'est de
dire j'ai pas besoin de tout ce je
marche je vend toutes mes affaires des
maps ainsi je vends tout mais en fa cup
à deux matches d'une vanne qui change
avec un lead dhabi tout le kit le puits
mais je pense que je serai moins heureux
je pense je serai plus
oui c'est bien moi j'y pense tellement
ça fait des mois moi ça me prend du
temps à prendre des décisions mais quand
je la prends comme je le souhaitais
montrer que je gère ça à un cube
longtemps et il ya plusieurs mois de dur
puis ça s'est un peu avec au dg
voyagistes j'ai vraiment aimé habiter à
bali m
j'ai vraiment aimé habiter à bali tout
s'est emballé je suis le plus chanceux
qui est habité à chengdu c'était une
chance dans ma vie je considère c'est
quelque chose qui m'est tombé sa tête
sur les réservant un titre est inchangé
je comprends mais c'est la grosse le
mois avait tombé sa tête puis et je
comprends que vous voulez me donner du
crédit
j'essaierai d'en chasser oui j'en ai
fait quelque chose de cool mais
heureusement pour moins que ça m'est
tombé sa tête
quelle chance puis ça m'a juste donné le
goût de voyager beaucoup tu es et le
maintenant moi je termine à tourner le 3
janvier 2020 au centre bell afin de
choses me faire raser les cheveux pour
le cas dans ma taille et une espèce de
cassures et on tourne on tourne la page
puis comme même physiquement ça va
physiquement par être ok il ya quelque
chose qui change
exact exactement et le lendemain je me
fais bleach et puis c'est déjà prévu
puis je le sais tpiy et après ce géant
vacances et la fac qui me ce que j'ai le
goût de faire que j'aimerais faire c'est
aller en nouvelle-zélande en liberté
vivent une vente et là on dirait que je
me suis beaucoup y penser j'ai lu un peu
là dessus j'ai acquis des trucs sur
instagram parce que c'est pas que
négatif
et je te jure j'avais commencé à écrire
une gamme qui ont des vingt dix et à mon
jab j'ai créé mes amis qui habitent
d'une vente présentement ici à montréal
j'étais comme que je préférais cet été
ici mon seul challenge c'est le frein
c'était la douche parce que si je me
lève j'ai un tournage faut que je prenne
une douche tous les bugs mais je te jure
ça me travaille un coin où j'ai jugé
goût de l'essayer ne serait-ce qu'une
semaine ou deux paraissent à ce que tu t
en ville le faire pour me ramener un peu
abattu parce que mon appart si je fais
des ménages
je vois juste dormir le jeu prend 2 que
je m'envole tiges reste jamais le fait
qu'à madrid car la bonne voie les prends
ta douche de 150 pièces pour une année
tu peux aller t'entraîner comme se prend
une douche n'importe quand n'importe où
sa filiale groupe jim je pourrais je
pourrais juste l'eau james et jusque
c'est là aussi c'est juste dans ma tête
m'enlever seule espèce de bonjour je
piquais samajam tout donner tout humain
il faut jamais aux toilettes coup
j'achète un paquet de gomme fait chier
c'est le toilettes
c'est quoi ça c'est juste puisque envoya
des plages mais bref paquet ya de quoi
loges comme ça me travaille tellement
mon gueule j'ai vraiment le goût puis je
pense que j'ai le tempérament pour
réussir à faire c'est la seule enfant
c'est que j'ai réalisé un bon gré qui
voyagent et c'est des fois t'es comme tu
t'es pas une autre personne ce bien
juste 100% tout voir je pense un peu
plus tôt c'est peut-être et eric en mai
en voyage c'est comme ça on voit plus la
personnalité du monde c'était comme tout
rester patient oppose sites illégaux et
mon peuple je pense je suis quand même
là c'est la face et quand chistian
montréalais 3d un jeu nerveux gens voir
s'il faut que j'arrive à l'heure parce
que la pression ce travail était plus
non plus défini par ta job search est
juste une personne examen puis là je me
suis dit j'ai déjà dit ça des amis comme
j'ai des amis de tank et dera pas quand
j'étais en australie
je parle à tout le monde c'est un enfant
puis j'aime pour coter pas de même ici
c'est d'aller parler à la personne
vraiment reste pas pareil
la plus forte qui est nette paris sait
peut être même enfin tu veux tu es ok je
te le fait d'imaginer la liberté que ça
donnerait ceci dit c'est le pillage que
complètement tombé dedans c'est une
kitten banjjak banjjak d'une maison à
gauche at il une votre vie augmente
après le mariage
l'appât du gain des paniers à gorge si
tu montes menton mais le manager chris
match je n'aime pas prête pas qui c'est
mais c'est un tel choc
les paiements tout est à faire plus tu
vis simplement plus tu peux juste parce
que tu aimes tu as envie puis peu
importe qui tu es ces crissements
quétaine puis-je elle est déjà dispo de
l'islam et je le pense vraiment un
métier
la vraie richesse de mennecy pendant
matériel pendant son compte de banque
mais les richesses et intérieurs cette
expérience de vie c'est l'écriture qui
est emmagasinée les personnes autour de
toi les relations qu'entretiennent ces
seules richesses et qu'on voit la
semaine prochaine on reçoit alexandre
champagne west ham en lui je pense que
vu que ce que fait dernièrement c'est
lui avait son studio champagne qui est
super beau local du clic et il y avait
sa tesla il y avait deux motos il y
avait tout tout tout ce stock puis là il
ya fait un tournant 180 degrés il ya
vendu son sort il ya vendu sa deuxième
moto il ya arrêté il ya déménagé dans un
local dans je pense et rosemont qui est
vraiment plus petits vraiment moins cher
puis il ya fait un post ou est ce que
c'est un vidéo lui qui parle explique
pourquoi fser midi que you feel you fait
son trip des gaules
pour lui il ya découvert qu'ils étaient
pas plus heureux avec les yeux tout
enlevé puis là il garde simplement le
strict minimum pour vivre correctement
je me joindrai de pau se mettre en règle
mais tout le reste tout son argent qui
va faire avec le studio avec séances
avec son livre son lait via pas pris une
scène de son livre j'ai tout donné ce à
l'organisme qui avec lequel travaillait
pour février le
la maison jean lapointe exactement exact
puis le dans le fond tout l'argent qui
va faire avec ces ateliers de
photographie premièrement il est
descendu le prix grandement pour tout le
monde
tout l'argent qu'on va faire avec ça il
va la mettre dedans pouvoir offrir des
ateliers de photographie à des familles
démunies
parce que lui expliquer que rien de plus
triste qu'une famille qui est pas de
photographier c'est une femme et qui ont
qui ont juste papa photo permet pas d'y
spot d'histoire dit à proprement parler
le fait que les voies tout transfert
j'arrive à mettre ça dans j'ai hâte d'y
en parler parce que oui parce que et une
fois que tu as goûté à six heures et au
goûter un certain succès à un certain
style de vie que d'être capable de dire
non ça c'est rien vraiment fou seat
d'avoir une tesla je comprends le sauf
que j'en ai pas besoin
j'ai pas besoin de ce matériel l'âge pas
besoin d'une deuxième moto j'ai besoin
de ces affaires lot et puis je trouve ça
vraiment hot je trouve que je trouve
cette instance et un estime au point
qu'on lui même c'est jim carrey qui
avait 10 à 12,9
et puis on s'entend là lui stagne au
niveau là il ya quelque chose de super
je pense ça revient un peu à ce qu'on
disait tantôt dans les extrêmes t il ya
quelque chose de je pense que puis c'est
un enfant de génération utile si c'est
des cycles un stylet on a tellement mes
parents pour eux le succès y ont grandi
à montréal puis pour eux réussissent
était il faut sortir de l'île fabre une
maison puis avoir un terrain puisque
c'était sur piste c'est ce qu'ils ont
réussi puis ils m'ont donné une qualité
vite moi quand j'ai déménagé à montréal
pour mais quitte lucerne au shit séance
sera pas ainsi qu'au lycée ça bouge et
puis c'est autre chose puis il avait ça
change c'est tout en mouvance hippie
mais sous sol fond de jeu des besoins
des jeunes le titre phare étions il ya
pas de problème
c'est en
gernez une hypothèque à payer 1 c'est
tout je vais déménager
j'ai pas de bouches à nourrir j'ai rien
rien du tout le tuer
les effacements aussi puis ça aussi
c'est quétaine métier quand je vois mon
neveu mini est et en santé c'est
vraiment quétaine je sais juste qu'ils
étaient partis de ces plâtres un mauvais
choix c'est vraiment plate le team est
les petits rentrent à l'école puisque
orange outre les enfants tout tout sur
mais tout est priorité puis sur
relativise toutes ces temps-ci jeu sur
mamma mia le musical tes jeux lecteur là
dedans pilotaris et pluvieux moi il ya
40 ans pis mais d'avoir une fille de sa
femme bruna petits lots pilotes avec idy
men je suis le genre puis j'ai juste
hâte d'aller voir ma fille gemma large
elle aime tellement
qu'est-ce que j'ai limité c'est une
telle voir sa première médaille depuis
il finissait son choix en disant depuis
j'ai une petite fille lumeau le stand up
s'est rendue la deuxième chose pour moi
l'été alors que c'était la première
chose je me tiens énormément de pression
mais il a depuis vu ma petite fille
le je m'en coller sur un peu l'addition
soit menti il disait de façon deuxième
niveau mais ses hôtes de pouvoir se
demande quand vainement un tremblement
voulez vous dit qu'il ne sais pas je
sais pas moi probablement que plus plus
je regarde ça plus j'adopterai un enfant
n'est plus adapté un enfant si j'avais
avoir un enfant puis je suis vraiment
pas sûr que c'est quelque chose qui me
tente encore mais si j'avais un bon
enfant pour un oiselet on dirait que
j'ai pas c'est d'avoir mettant des gènes
qui se perpétue on dirait que c'est pas
quelque chose qui - on à intéresser des
six bons gènes en plus faudrait que ça
m'intéresse pas rexam ça me parle pas ce
n'est pas quelque chose que je ressens
le besoin
on dirait
mais je me suis plus dans la non
adoption
je n'ai parlé avec nicolette way puis
lui est adopté puis j'ai trouvé que
c'est par un long il ya vraiment un
orgueilleux alors je trouve y est il
vraiment vraiment j'admire seconde
vraiment épatant brillant accessible
humble il est extraordinaire puis quand
j'ai parlé de cela n'est pas assez à je
veux tout savoir justement j'étais quand
même en parler d'adoption firme mais je
me sens très redevable avait parents
j'ai l'impression de leur genre en dois
je pourrai jamais leur remettre ce
qu'ils m'ont donnée par gilles j'ai reçu
je pourrai jamais dire assez merci à mes
parents comme toi vu qu'a été adoptée
est ce que ce sentiment est encore plus
fort chez toi lui dit pas du tout pas du
tout il à cause de mes parents mes
parents je trouve certainement
intéressant c'est pareil on dit souvent
les gens disent que l'adoption c'est un
mouvement le moulin le geste le plus
généreux que pourraient faire les
parents négocié au contraire nous on
trouve ces égoïstes non on voulait un
enfant
on a juste été chercher un enfant si on
le fait fac tu ne dois rien du tout et
on était un être humain à part entière
piste indoor et waouh c'est quelle
puissance et que seppi il ya quelque
chose de très fort aussi dans un petit
je trouve ça intéressant aussi voir si
je vois des enfants grandissent et mon
neveu 5 1 nice 3 1 mon hôte signé un
salaire de moins 10 c'est fascinant de
voir qu'il y ait promis la famille comme
ceux mis là c'est la deuxième est de
même parce que c'est la deuxième un peu
pour ma soeur qui rend du maire ma mère
qui est grand mère mon père grand père
voit tout le monde n'est pas par aimé
voir quand même lit asti sais pas mais
ma femme un père une mère mon père m'a
déjà dit il ramène je t'aime plus que ma
propre vie mais je t'aimerai jamais
comme ta mère t'aiment je la voie libre
que jamais capable de tout ça
jamais le même temps mon père m'amenait
autre chose que maman maman de potes
pourquoi je pose la personne qui a le
plus confiance en moi de toute ma vie
mais mon panneau aucun doute sur ma
personne à tous les niveaux tout fout le
camp
je suis en train d'en changer son je te
quitte le chéquier jay 14 15 heures il
me montrait à chauffer le tracteur avec
vite dans le champ le lendemain il ya
une cargaison mais une livraison de huit
mille bouteilles de vin car il sait des
palettes de huit mille bouteilles vite
parce qu'on vend bouteiller sont 1 53
pieds moi je d'un tracteur vraiment
étroit fer qui balance beaucoup
l'appel mon père principaux leur plume
pas et une livraison de 20 août a été
blessé je m'étais pas là pour les
débarquer nom et tout le séjour est cher
quand c'est fini
huit minutes et quand ça m'aide à
trouver tracts à démontrer ouais fallu
aguets j'ai fait il ya quelque chose
j'ai réalisé plus tard la puissance de
tir et la puissance de quelqu'un que tu
admires que vraiment profondément
confiance en toi quel point ça il me
fait faire faire des enfants que comme
je pensais que j'étais capable de faire
je les fait vraiment fascinant je trouve
dans la le lien avec les parents puis
tout petit comme c'est fascinant enfin
me bats c'est fascinant c'est tellement
dur est enfant plus de 4 c'est rien
maintenant tout à stx et durent 6
chimène c'est comme tu penses tu du job
et y dispose pas déplacé mais tu sais
pas tu quittes je sais c'est pas réagi
du mans b à stx et acheter des fois les
gens retournent au prix m'a jamais
jamais que je retrouverai tout sauf à la
merde voilà est enfin puis je m'en rends
compte aujourd'hui parce que moi j'ai
grave je jamais déplaire
ouais et enfin ça fait en sorte que ou
aujourd'hui je tiens à linge beaucoup
excellent parce que le jeu chef fight
compte quelque chose de viscéral mais
j'ai envie de me faire personne ne
m'attend j'ai comme fo qui tu me fais
personae mais je sais que ça va déplaire
à du monde les espèces qu'ils font
passer puisque matin si j'enlève tout
moi sommes tant gaujal fait mais c'est
comme un espèce cinq enfants
j'étais comme jeu
je pencherais j'étais un bon kid seppi
mais je voudrais je deviens de plus en
plus rebelles devient de plus en plus
moi aussi mais c'est juste pour cette
fascinante et un kid ya de quoi devrait
en ford a juste choisi et safe et ses
potes d'apprécier d'angoissantes et moi
j'écoutais un film mais la semaine
passée tpiy il se passait qui arrivés de
kuala enfants s'est jeté comme un
michael s'il fallait qu'ils se posent de
quoi je me suis imaginé s'il fallait qui
arrive quelque chose à montmagny est à
venir et je pète une note ça marche put
et puis c'est pas mes enfants je me suis
dit imagine quand c'est ton kid le jour
pas ça moi quand j'ai eu mon cher à 16
ans puis commence à rentrer à 5 heures
du matin à marseille posté ou gicam as
sikkah le pot dormi mais ne s'est pas
français a duré à lui seul autre côté
même année j'ai eu le réflexe tarifs
belgique juin je m'excuse pas comme bien
d affaire
je m'excuse iphoto pas que je comprenne
une marine ça arrive pas dormir ci est
quoi la révolte réparatrice elle est
inquiète
moi ma marraine à ya encore dix nuits à
celle là matin ces méthodes est faux je
passe beaucoup de gens chez eux quand je
vois qu'avec tes clem et anti s'est
défaussé des niaiseries le sait comme
des factures pour des impôts ou genre
est droit dans mon pays alors j'ai pas
dormi de la nuit juste par cette facture
au titre de même ces cas là mangeant à
voler les salles et je te vois tellement
insisté pas de maman je pencherais en
prison pourquoi payer mes charges assez
sur she's la fraude jusqu'à jusqu'à le
ma vision c'est maman qui a prié ses
incroyables jusqu'à ma gueule que
geoffrey gaquère europe les caisses vont
faire comme moi je vais être pas bon
enfant que moi je pense qu'elle est
passée comme le moment où est ce que
c'est bien là tout comme google à qui le
fougueux choix cette personne le projet
doit aussi se rendre etc c'est exact
parce qu'ils étaient obligés d'être un
parent atteint que poté parade
pour lui d'agir en tant que papa temps
que moi de là c'est admirable man avec
des paroles magiques moi je pense pas
que je pense pas que c'est quelque chose
qui du moins pour l'instant je passe
taper le mot haiti est déjà d'accord ces
différents sites et nos parents témoin
mes parents la plupart des gens de notre
génération nous parents nous ont eu
surtout dans la vingtaine aujourd'hui
c'est plus rare c'est ainsi que les gens
que j'admire le plus mes idoles c'est
des gens qui ont leurs enfants très tôt
je pense que c'est on est rendu plus le
team oman 103 89 ans puis mais sa fidèle
équipe son mari sorin autres il y avait
16 17 ans et cette fois ça y est t'es
rendu loupé sa fête au bouc match
extraordinaire
moi je pense que je rendais qui de la
journée où mon neveu va pouvoir les
garder parce qu'on parle un peu de temps
pas de caste y est ce à quoi j'ai un peu
et j'ai envie ça va être plein
d'affaires s'est passé j'ai appelé cette
j'ai du temps discute pas je vais pas
donner d'angle précis à ce que ça allait
être j'avais plein d'idées souvent comme
un ch'ti jeudi soit je sais rien
astiquez je sais rien
puis fax comme aller chez moi je vais
apprendre des choses
voilà c'est plus dans la prend plus que
tu sais que c'est rien c'est ça ma
pression je suis revenu à la base j'ai
fait c'est quoi je refais un jeu juste
juste passer des bons moments
c'est sûr je veux juste un bon moment
fait que ça va surtout et où on one mais
je veux pas avoir de limites c'est
qu'évidemment je rencontrais des gens
connus des différents milieux mais j'ai
aussi rencontré possiblement des
enseignants wever imation si vous
revenez régulièrement des jeux comme pas
moi je quelqu'un vient trois fois 6 mois
je peux je veux pas me limiter si un ou
deux et au studio que je reçois
quelqu'un que vous intéresse
enfin que mr le des micropuces a fini de
témoins c'est pas grave c'est ça que je
veux juste passer des bons moments
puis discuté avec du monde que ce que je
trouve fascinant maintenant de cellules
puisqu'on est en tain de ses classes au
menton n'est pas son téléphone puis
ultime ans on aurait probablement dit en
passant je trouve ça m'est arrivé
souvent d'avoir des conversations des
amis en chat ou au début quand tu as
arrêté un bon podcast est oui
cachet d amigo express c'est comme deux
ans au plus fort de la crise t'intéresse
ouais ça qui est un peu déçu je veux
juste juste passer un bon moment avec
des gens que j'admire que je connais ou
que je connais peu que je connais pas
ces gestes puis de là aussi le fait
d'avoir différencier mon podcast puis
maintenant je veux tout savoir je veux
te servent souvent de l'entrevue si je
me sens tout savoir sur l'autre personne
mon podcast vais pas me gêner de données
- une poutre de prendre une place doit
exactement mais ouais je pense que oui
mais si je veux apprendre des choses que
je questionner je changer d'idée je veux
me tromper c'est ce que je veux tu veux
que je vois je rencontre plein de gens
j'ai déjà lancé des petites lignes à
l'eau mais il ya plein de personnes qui
est des fois je croise t j'ai la chance
maintenant de rencontrer plein de
personnes city mais aussi ses tournées
michel barrette son émission vient de
faire un autre
et puis le fait c'est quoi ma fille
c'est goliath pour recevoir d'ivoire un
podcast qui trouve alors je me souviens
pas ne pas le connaître un lent terral
m'envoie civray et le jeu me ramos assis
avec lui d'une cadillac 68 puis puis on
jase pis puis on connecte le c'est un
vrai moment de répit autant en ondes que
or dont on je n'arrête pas de jazz et
puis on se pose plein de questions
plaidons est intéressé fia comme un
crime jugé
je veux tout savoir de ce que leur dit
j'ai envie de le rencontrer j'ai envie
qu'on j'ai envie qu'on discute j'ai
envie qu'on fait qu'ils aient fait
autant lui que olivier à rebours moss
qui cherrad qui est un journaliste et
que à chaque fois je le croise à chaque
fois je vois si c'est aussi vidéos jeux
comme mail ce gala a tellement de choses
pertinentes à dire j'ai envie d'y poser
des questions puis d'apprendre mon
meilleur chum qui est avocat qui me
parle t il fait il fait tellement
d'affaires fait du bénévolat lui et
origine syrienne va aider les nouveaux
arrivants syrien
faites des espèces de peau des
conférences le mât appelons ça une
petite conférence le des sous-sols
d'église en anglais et en arabe pour les
nouveaux arrivants leur montrer comment
signer un bail
c'est quoi leur droit et faut qu'on
entende ses histoires ses paquets il ya
quelque chose d je veux je veux
apprendre je rencontre et je veux
découvrir et j'écris de la cus et
nourrir ma curiosité
c'est vraiment ce que je veux que ce
soit puis après ceux ci un soir j'ai
envie qu'elle a un mandat soir c'est le
super bowl où les oscars on le met live
ici écouter les oscars avec nous autres
en live
puis on s'amuse si j'ai déjà fait un
facebook live des oscars avec 88 des
bocages pendant les pauses
c'était tellement le fun c'était
tellement le fun au taquet c'est logique
quand je prends une limite et je veux le
tout pour faire puis mettons qu'en 2020
je pars en voyage mais j'aimerais
peut-être se faire des plus petit
podcast mais moi tout seul qui parle de
gens suis que j'ai fait que j'ai vu
enfin que je pense que ça va prendre
plein de force et puis
et puis je veux juste mais complètement
mais me laisser porter par la vague
cette affaire l'outil tués dans tout le
projet ça me fascine prenant ce que tu
dis là est une cinq médailles en tout le
projet du studio c'est que c'est ça
qu'on n'arrête pas de cette durée ou
quelques mois on dirait que je suis
obsédé par le fait que c'est amusant c
c'est à nous autres fake toi tu dis est
maintenant on peut tu m'aimes tu es là
avec les oscars
of course qu'on peut faire c'est aux
autres où tu veux qu'un dimanche
justement un dimanche et où les au score
de 7 à 9
tu veux être si oui mais on peut alors
on peut même de laquelle je l'accueille
6,6 et nous disent que c'est moi ça me
fait rire fait capoter tout les trucs
emploi for pi au delà de thé chacun les
podcasts respectifs s'arrête de pouvons
juste faire n'importe quoi
un spécial ever wade veut qu'on veut
parler de n'importe quoi n'importe quel
invité qui est au québec pour une
semaine d'un espèce de podcasts rapide
on a la liberté absolue j'ai un jeu
c'est pas ce sentiment là mais souvent
ça m'arrive sur différentes mais projet
que ce soit mon show que ce soit les
shows télé ou même le podcast studio
souvent j'ai senti match comme crémieux
pas d'adultes qui nous soutiennent
existe en voiture et s'appauvrit mois ci
ce qui me fascine c'est que j'aimerais
entrer dans ma tête j'ai encore un kit
que besoin d'être surveillés
j'aime bien j'ai 27 ans j'ai mangé mon
père me conduis je vote et je ma job je
fais ce que je veux tpiy maîtresse
ouvrages comme un manga tirade une zone
si nous autres c'est comme se laver
partie variable en fait si on le fait un
qui pleut on est assis sous hommes y'a
pas l'adulte qui nous sauve elle mène
ses musées on fait ce qu'on veut
or merouana ces malades je sais pas si
ça feeling le port un jour je sais pas
parce que nos parents dans le fond
aucune disent qu'il faut non plus
puisque vatican
demain quand tu pars avec tes parents
aux candidats avec qui je parlais
français
si comme qu'un sur trois surtout quand
tu rencontres des gens d'une autre
génération que tu arrives tu dit on a
jusqu'à jeudi qu'une en 91
merci c'est comme il réalise voix
poitiers je pense qu'ils et puis c'est
la même chose pour ce mois je me sens
comme si j'avais 16 ans je n'ai 26
j'approche de 30 un moulage ça me fait
pas parce que dans mon métier c'est cool
vieilli mais reste com - 27 ans quand je
dis c'est bizarre je pense qu'en effet
ça paraît pas mais faut pas que ça parte
c'est ce rapport avec ça si je pense que
l'une des raisons pour lesquelles si oui
quand même que lee trois bâtons
rétrograde 27 ans on trippe sur un gain
de 53 qui s'appelle john lang 53 54
c'est à temps le jeu qu'est ce qui fait
qu'on qui relètent autant avec nous
autres c'est qu'il cultive sa curiosité
il permet de se tromper puis de change
et du dépit des six gardes ntc sur les
adultes les punaises toi c'est des gens
qui resterait que tu leur parles si moi
j'avais maintenant plus il ment c'est la
grande tente a man mais c'est ma grand
tante elle attend ta maman et sa maman
rien de bien décédé en 2013 mais et 2014
et bien tu parlais comme attendu si le
pister comme je parlais qu'une femme de
mon âge ce qu'un seul st com était
tellement à lui mais tellement le
tellement curieuse tellement intéressé à
l'autre je suis assez sûr je trouve le
fun je pense que les podcasts emmène
subts on en parlais tantôt très
d'empathie mais je pense qu'il y ait
jamais trop d'empathie l'empathie amen à
tout site est empathique tu vas être
plus ouverts tu vois tu seras jamais
sexistes soit jamais raciste de
l'empathie tu vas tu te mets à la place
de l'autre c'est ok c'est le podcast je
sais pas pourquoi sa minceur mais y'a de
quoi le jeu truqué et on
c'est juste sous les auspices en serbie
nourrir sa curiosité sa peugeot cette
bombe les deux choses d'abord le mic les
écouteurs dire on est là pour ce ça à
laives l'espèce dacquois une espèce
devenue qu'on a des fois tu es dans le
genre très parce que jacques arrêt
jamais perso tu es je veux pas accaparer
quelqu'un pendant deux heures plaisir on
j'entends ça où on joue comme ça où je
vois où je sais pas je me sentir à
cuinchy pour parler de moi vous parlez
de poser des questions c'est un peu plus
digne
quand on est là pour ça c'est comme ok
on se quitte les premières étapes puis
on va dire d'enlever du sujet n'est pas
d'autre part les jo le guen qui a 53 ans
puis moi est quelque chose qui dit que
j'attends de dire plusieurs fois kim qui
me rassure qui me fait du bien quand il
se serait caché dans la vingtaine qui
est ce que j'étais con way
j'avais rien puis jetés t aujourd'hui je
loge
j'ai l'air de connaître des enfants
habitaient encore dit il sent le fake
l'été mais j'étais content et pis si on
est juste au début notre vie mais c'est
quand tu réalises ça que ça enlève une
pression très dans 30 ans 40 ans 50 ans
envoie être même un vrai mac à nantes à
l'été est encore en première moitié de
ta vie humaine bien résultats en
quarantaine l'horloge s'est dit il ya
vraiment j'écoutais encore une fois j'ai
écouté un podcast
ça fait une couple de fois que j'en
parle sur le sans fil mais c'est un
podcast sur le processus de
vieillissement
c'est joe rogan leur suspect qui
s'appelle david sinclair d'organes leur
superbe sur huit fois leur sujet écoute
et cela crée trop puis le guide il ya
vraiment une distinction claire en loge
physique puis l'âge intellectuelle ces
deux affaires qui sont le vieillissement
physique et le vieillissement
intellectuels ces deux choses qui sont
complètement différentes
le vieillissement physique c'est quelque
chose que tu ton troll plus ou moins
mais le vieillissement intellectuelle
c'est quelque chose que du contrôle à
100%
puis j'ai l'impression qu'il ya beaucoup
deux personnes de notre âge qui sont
beaucoup plus vieux intellectuellement
d'autres beaucoup plus jeunes bien du
monde vieux physiquement qui reste
complètement juin intellectuellement par
pagesjaunes au sens et christiane qui
m'attire entré en jeu nos sens
allumez allumé intéresser un curieux
exergue la curiosité l'attention qu'ils
portent moins une des personnes que je
connais qu'il a possiblement la personne
la plus qui m'apparaît la plus
intelligente des gens que je connais je
connais c'est étienne la vallée c'est un
enjeu qui ont mangés puis lui ce qui
fait qui est capable d'être aussi
brillant que c'est quand je lui parle il
écoute à 100 pour ça il coûte à 100% il
pas en train de penser à qu'est-ce qui
va dire après il pas en train de penser
à qu'est ce qu'il va faire le soir ils
écoutent à 100% parce que tu lui dis
devient une connaissance qui a dit ceci
c'est une force énorme peluche persuadé
que quand que voir son dix ans il va
alors la même curiosité que maintenant
et curiosité puis la même rosselat
d'ordinaire formation le mundillo gaz
qui impressionne souvent c'est que
quelque chose quelque chose qui tient
ici sur un podcast le 2010 par là
quelqu'un tu as we un tel mode issue 1
puis andriole mais moi ils capables de
ressortir les informations j'aime le
fait impression beaucoup moi la personne
la plus intelligente que j'ai rencontré
de ma vie c'est un gars qui s'appelle
thomas de koninck et qu'il prof de philo
on y verser la balle qui a fait aussi un
gîte j'ai découvert comme tout le monde
la philo puis je vais rattraper puis le
génie de la musique puis mettons se
mettront si je t'ai pas aller en musique
à l'université j'avais décidé maintenant
de faire autre chose sa musique je serai
les titans fille l'autre c'est tellement
intéressant la philo en fait c'est comme
un réformiste mais c'est comme les
affaires reste un bon prof
bah ouais c'est extra salon protos et gt
seul zanetti maintenant ils députés pour
québec solidaire
quant à di sole jeter comme seul
un bon preuve fico h'mimed webisodes
canadien salim audi à l'université ce
qui voyait vraiment engagée par la philo
budget mais sans pitié
j'hésitais presque à halifax il m'a dit
si tu vas musique prend moins d'écho en
faculté parce qu'on a tous des côtes
domaine faut faire en filou puis prend
des cours avec de koninck
puis c'est ce que ça va changer d'avis
c'est ce que j'ai fait avec le premier
coup que j'ai fait je me suis inscrit
c'était genre de cours sur un traité
d'aristote vraiment arrive vraiment
difficile entrée en matière en
philosophie de ces méthodes puis est
arrivé le ggul premièrement thomas de
koninck et qui sont par est un graphe
les offres sont patents grand philosophe
aussi charles de koninck
d'ailleurs ya un pavillon à l'inversé
laval qui est en son nom dans la légende
birkin ceci lui même lui même je pense
qu'ils confirment qu'ils avaient comme
la preuve
assistante à lui confirme que c'est est
ce que c'est vrai charles deconninck
sont pas y était très ami avec eux
saint-exupéry l'otan qui c'est lui qui a
écrit les petits princes puis légende
voudrait qu'il lui serait venu au québec
pendant parce que l'on avait une grande
maison sur le bord du fleuve à québec
sur chaque hôtel château frontenac
puis les autres savaient tout autour du
monde la maison des intellectuels des
artistes pop c'était vraiment une espèce
de il y avait plein d'enfants tpiy
grosse grosse famille ou qui espèrent
tous des intellectuels sa famille reste
du monde donc on combat qui ont des
grandes carrières intellectuelle on
connaît bien au défi m
ouais c'est une famille les génisses une
famille des génies vraiment toute la
gamme puis il ya toute une page
wikipédia tous des frères et soeurs puis
c'est tout et professeur d'université et
puis des leaders dans leur domaine
pis cela qui était juste une cependant
pas sur excel - intellectuelle
pour aller à l'université c'est lui que
le plus réussi en affaires de la famille
c'est l'équivalent kunda plus d'argent
sa femme est partie d'une compagnie tout
exemple maintenant de moi c'est le plus
vieux la famille équipe i saint-exupéry
serait venu au québec tant qu'etat moi
il y avait comme sept ans qu'ils sont
par les philosophes qu'il est petit et
puis les enfants sont tous philosophes
mais lui à un autre degré s'est plus
posé des questions sur tout qui a vite
commencé petit gollop y retourner en
france puis réécrit le petit prince tu
fais qu en parlant de thomas way en
n'ayant qu'un mot en tête ses ouailles
et moi j'ai eu thomas comme prof
il y avait 80 ans avec les petits
presque devenu un peu assurée les jambes
qui est assez établi que ce serait seule
pouliche épi sur enclos pileux goulot
this is it de loin la personne
intelligente qui que je connais par les
huit langues dont le grec ancien ces
piles et puis ça s'est quand même utile
jacques anthian arrive assez plat tout à
fait tarifs pour passer son taux
directeur photo et mon métier il y
platon aristote en langue originale
si tu lis platon aristote
c'est fascinant comme en 2006 lui à 80
is it is it et tous ses livres il se
doit avouer qu'ils avaient 20 mai lieu
chez eux qui étaient là bas il dit je
sais pas mais ma femme dickens à peu
près 20 me direz vous évidemment il
prendra toute l'ue puis il s'est ici des
mémoires des affaires puis d'une seco
déco magistraux trois heures des
mémoires ou is who is who is it oui
c'est exactement ce qu'ils savent opi
ségolène à y avait 80 puis c'est la
personne la plus allumés que j'ai jamais
vu parce que j'avais arrêté de l'est et
jamais arrêtés des curieux et j'ai
arrêté d'être philosophe jamais arrêté
d'enseigner l'art est il pour s'arrêter
dans la france 83 août en fin de vie et
au dessus
il était accessible y était comme du
comprenez il était des fois
moi ce sont les gens les plus
intelligents c'est pas nécessairement
les gens qui semblent nécessairement les
plus intelligents souvent c'est chaud
c'est des gens qui s'expriment à d'une
manière où je trouve les gens les plus
intelligents c'est les personnes qui te
font sentir intelligent ouais je sais
moi j'ai pas eu une relation de
proximité et cela parce que tu aimais
tant que la fête dans la maîtrise et au
doctorat
l'homme étant ça a été mon tracteur
gérer et traiter du cas avec métier je
pense qu'elle est une ou deux fois son
bureau lui parler des bruits bras au
coeur c'est un régal
pis puis je me souviens le pis si c'est
un bon and day avec à travailler dans
nos vieux monsieur c'est là la courbure
du vieil homme il y avait les yeux bleus
il y avait une espèce de de jeunesse
dans ses yeux je me souviens l'avoir
gardé dans le fond des yeux d'abord
avoir vu un petit prince
c'était vraiment un grand coup dès le
ce1 avec ces gars là justement on
parlait de rester actif de rester ici le
plus grand exemple que le connaître lui
jugé est-ce que tu considères que
changer ta vie d'une manière autonome je
pense que oui parce que ségo de sa mère
d'enseigner ces pauvres
ok voici la matière clac clac c'est
comme un voyage ou à la fin du côté seul
bouton chaise petit pour avoir la
réponse
les gars est ton qu il eu pendant une
semaine tu penses tu lis encore petit a
fait comprendre que tu arrives à l'autre
puis au début
justement je trouvais dans la classe
d'aristote que je comprenais mais faux
col c'était comme hawkish carrément pas
ma place ici qu'il y avait sur les
stands monnaies qui donne des ordres
d'ateliers genre de cours sur le court a
pas d exercice vie par des équipes
presque des jeux à te fait comprendre ce
qui vient de se passer est mon pilote
comme une épiphanie pu te fais ok qu'il
le jeu comprend qu'ils puissent
accepter une session à chaque semaine
vraiment faire l'action de philosophie
de poser des questions de se trouver la
réponse c'est platon c'est la caverne
sortir de la caverne qui voit les choses
pour répéter c'est vraiment cette espèce
de défendre leur tekki ébloui au début
mais qu'a finalement tu vois la beauté
des choses
ben ça a été un voyage dans mexico et
puis je dire prix locaux après tout j'ai
répondu commencer le plateau plutôt qu
alstom mais j'ai fait l'inversé
puis justement antilles ap l'at on
s'était vraiment j'avais carrément
secrète s'allume compter que à l'époque
luca lui était une versatilité un peu
plus jeunes étaient dans 61 10
pittis a capté dans les écrits c'est
comme si il était très genre devait
beaucoup au pt buvait jusqu'à accès
élèves ou avec ses disciples 14 ans mais
matri à cet article hello pileux il
continue et challenger mon petit il
faisait des conneries qu'on allait
prendre une bière avec ils venaient les
autres sont des gentils dit quelque
chose qu'à deux armées à huit heures
était dans son cours charpy des
naissances la légende les gens vraiment
la carnation s'inquiète du monde tripper
ses gammes de gens qui sont seulement
une princesse personne ne sait ce qui
est cool tiges trop ce que c'est qu'un
jeu souvent maintenant les gens qui ont
beaucoup voyagé ces des gens qui ont sur
un espèce de wisdom est juste sincère et
une médium que qui réalisateur il ya
beaucoup voyagé pendant que ça sent
juste dans sa personne et icom tellement
ouvert puis
c'est ce que je trouve forte et c'est
que l'ouverture d'esprit on a tellement
à apprendre de tout le monde c'est
beaucoup ce désir leur moi aujourd'hui
puis de leurs que ça passe
à écouter des podcasts allait la tuer et
d'enlever la musique à découvrir des
trucs jeu se nourrir culturellement et
justes socialement c'est tellement forte
et humainement parlant c'est que c'est
sûr se fasse non l'être humain fait
signer les relations humaines sont
fascinantes surtout direct chaque
histoire et trippante qui tout le monde
peut être cette personne c'est ce qui
coûte
puis je sais qu'il ya des gens qui
naissent dans des conditions plus
favorables que d'autres mais je crois
vraiment peut-être que c'est naïf
peut-être parce que je t'aime acheminés
dans what que dans ma tête tout est
possible pour tout le monde sait mais qu
ancien parti croate
je pense que tout le monde le pouvoir on
est plus en contrôle qu'on le parle tout
le monde le pouvoir d'améliorer sa
situation très peu importe même si il y
en a qui ont des cartes de marde l'envi
on dit que vraiment des calques et
enrichie avec une paire d'arcy
sauf que moi qui ai toujours par des
petites actions de justice qui
j'améliore une petite affaire à chaque
jour dans ma vie qui fait que tu as many
to le contrôle sur quelques tracts en vo
c'était pas le contrôle sur ses moi je
tiens mon temps de parler nicolas ouédec
moi j'ai un ami guillaume tondreau qui
est musicien pis on parlait de serre un
épi team qui luttent haddad adoptée ici
de six mois dit j'ai passé proche de
gras dans une tente en haïti le jeter à
l'eau oui mais ça veut pas et que tu te
vois quoi que ce soit personne n'a qu'un
mot il dit j'étais chanceuse d'être
adoptée juste et le bain et peu plus
chanceux que moi mais j'ai été chanceux
en crise de vie des nattes rousses qui
fut ni pitié 5 e fax email oui en
écailles qui met d'histoire de même sur
mon entraîneur ouais que vous avez
rencontré alex était venu ici
alex inea et 6 puis son vrai nom son
il sait si alex doré puis il est adopté
il ya grandi à chicoutimi comme exact
des années 80 il n'y avait pas de la
qualité et ne comptait que son vrai nom
c'est original c'est oui parce que
mettons rénale sportstm ainsi dans ces
coins le doyen notamment axa et j'oublie
à ce que mais bref
raynal bon sam hockey est bon salle jean
macé sinon t'es par entièrement il lui
sa mère l'a couché puis à 6 pouces et il
connaît pas en paca n'a pas sa main donc
son nom de famille c'était le nom de la
place où habitaient les leurres féline
s'appelait bon samaritain en plus était
scellé madalle leur fille naïve et bien
on va l'appeler et thé raynaldy bon sam
et lui n'était pas supposé être adoptée
c'est par un tel sens et adopter un
autre petit garçon plus tire son temps
mais mardi a dû aller à l'hôpital je
peux vous ce qui s'est passé va
finalement les parents ne fait plus
adopter c'était kid lucky qui était
censé adapter dont qui ont eu lui pied
comme il me contait c'est pour s'en
aller manger au mini mélo sur jean-talon
une place haïtienne depuis quand les
femmes c'est quoi les fortes chances que
tous plus monstrueux
aujourd'hui si c'est quoi les chances
que lui - on soit dans le même genre
qu'on s'entende bien qu'on soit des
sommes dont on passe du temps ensemble
ça mais ça me fascine c'est fascinant
les puits c'est mon meilleur chum syrien
s'est même fait ses parents sont plus et
pour ainsi sa séparation rendu à
l'hôpital pour la coucher en métro en ne
sachant pas lire le français est tué
mais qu'elle les eaux et a brisé son
dans le métro mène bien merci
j'imagine le sentiment d'écrire
l'histoire c'est fascinant
puis ces gens là sont tellement doux
tellement gentils nous reçoive a su
paiement il fallut jeudi à sahm emmené
le faut arrêter de donner de la
nourriture
j'ai pu faire faut que ça cesse
immédiatement commis à paris je dise un
peu siècle ça comprenez
ça va toucher bonne fille capable le
faut que ça cesse
on arrête là non échange de [ __ ] mais
il ya quelque chose de tellement c'était
déjà tellement on a quelque chose à
apprendre tout le monde sait quelle
histoire c'est celle von magnet super
league mes parents si juste mes parents
sont ensemble depuis 15 ans et on sait
pas comme on connais pas la vie nos
parent non bannie je me suis inscrit jfr
jeunesse global ouais non c'est simple
mais par an grâce à montréal que j'avais
à mourir c'est votre premier appart ça à
telle ou telle adresse t telle plage
apprécions le déminage à telle place en
attendant d'une maison à lachenaie
les tarifs de rachat commune c'est comme
même astoul 15 minutes puis pose des
questions à ton pain boîtes à malle à
audard grand manteau dans les histoires
c'est fascinant tout le monde a une
histoire fascinante sûr c'est vraiment
moi j'ai quand même un grand mère est
décédée la mère de ma mère j'ai je suis
allée avec ma soeur souper chez mon
grand père ils ont reçu à super piste
est la première fois de toute ma vie que
je voyais mon grand-père ce c'est ma
soeur est avec moi mais qu'on voyait mon
grand papa dans un contexte fostier
papier dans un party de famille ou
espagnols c'est tout pas que les enfants
lutte avec les adultes puis une
fourchette preppy on a juste parlé il
m'a raconté des histoires que j'avais
même aucune idée je n'avais jamais
entendu parler d'eux seuls ces affaires
de foule tient à mener c'est fait le
travail joue du piano au manoir saint
castin au lac beauport les était
d'amener c'est comme amouraché d'une
file à bord qui était une fille d'un
riche américain plus qu'inquiet elle est
repartie vivre en floride
son père payer un mois de mon papy pour
qu'ils se rendent l'eau puis le vevak la
famille il compte sur l'autre ces
malades je n'ai jamais subi si c'est
parce que ça c'est juste une mine
histoire est appréciée dit crise car on
verra pas va mourir ces histoires ils
s'en vont avec
beatty c'est un cliché du cac à une
vieille personne meurt c'est une
bibliothèque qui brûle
imaginez les histoires qu'on accumule
maintenant on est jeune
toutes les histoires qu'on a accumulé
toutes les histoires qu'on raconte quand
c'est le temps de faire rire toutes ces
affaires le les highlights qu'on se
rappelle quand tu es rendu à 85 b en
live des histoires insein des histoires
loufoques des trucs tarifs qui ne font
pas de sens raconté ça à un enfant à un
jeune intéressé ils transmettent et sur
le sait-on vécu ses skis ski toi tu
animes puisqu'il va disparaître avec toi
est quelque chose de poétique d'un
dentiste idée là je trouve ce beau pays
je trouve je trouve que encore le jeu ne
s'est pas vraiment améliorée je prends
pas nécessairement le temps d'aller tuer
parler comme ça avec avec mes
grands-parents mais j'ai l'impression
qu'avec en en faisant un peu ce qu'on
ainsi de faire la paix avec le podcast
s'enfla tétreault le podcast encore dans
le sens du poil mais ce qu'on essaie de
faire l'os et de faire ressurgir su
donner une vie assez à faire le tri
entre ce que je trouve ça je trouve sera
d'imaginer ça comme ça je trouve ça
permet une certaine perpétuité de de
quelque chose dessus
absolument pour d'autres mondes parce
que le grand pas de la londe qui
viennent de se dire ça fait quelques
semaines lui mais nous conter les
histoires le tout le temps c'est mon
grand père à moi même si je suppose des
questions évidemment compter sauf que
les remparts à lienz c'est comme ça me
fait penser une fois qu'il est parti
soutient la fouille travaillé chez
molson avec jean béliveau puisqu'elle a
commenté un bon groupe qui était ce
mardi qui avait envoyé une lettre à
manier pour le remercier de telles
affaires puis le plein d'histoires seppi
c'est incroyable qu'ils étaient à
l'hôpital juste avant qu'ils comptent
aller le voir je savais qu'ils marty qui
il si le yen
des affaires les manies des traits d'un
restaurant père c'est bon les fruits de
maths imaginer tout à fait sûr que je
posais des questions sur jean béliveau
son histoire d'y croire qu'ils se
voyaient même la loi dans ses yeux quand
il s'est agi au flanc contre la salle et
tout cela est juste à la nitro de parler
des deux mondes a fait au sud c'est
utile au jeu 5 et maintenant je sais que
c'est important que je fasse un pas tout
j'ai tout le long de la conversation
surtout quartier après un certain talent
comme quand tu vois un bon show ça
allait [ __ ] la fin arrive que ça
finisse
puis comme lire un bon livre si tu veux
tout savoir maintenant tu veux pas le
fait n'est pas c'est bon tout le long du
podcast et le sentiment que j'avais à
chaque fois je t'ai propos de cassis
comme j'ai pas fini c'est un moment le
terrain sur ce riche au sol phone puis
je vous remercierai jamais assez pour se
les gardent de voir ton podcast
j'ai tellement été produites et
tellement ceux qui nous écoutent en ce
moment je regardais hakem le ceux qui
nous écoutent en ce moment restez à
l'affût pour le podcast de jay jay dit
on discute ça va être sourd et ça a
diffusé partout sur le les plateformes
ya sur le web à 127 les femmes c'est
vraiment les boys puis bravo et merci à
toi
[Musique]